they find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically the hearing on all bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today an
executive session may be held on any
bills referred to the committee please
note there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee in the select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporariously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporariously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with the house
rules and RSA 1A anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call
271-3600 or email HCS
ledge.state.nh.us in the event the
public is unable to access
this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all the votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
all right Keith you're on
all right roll call Representative hunt
here in uh I'm all alone
I'm here I'm alone in my upstairs hobby
room
not here representative Ammon here
representative Abramson
representative ham here alone
representative De Palma here alone
representative greeson present and alone
here alone in the room at the moment but
I do have two teenage daughters who are
representative Terry
I am present I am here by myself in this
room at this time uh my wife is in the
house
representative Bartlett
representative Abel
I'm here I'm by myself
representative Herbert
I'm here my wife is in her office
representative Fargo
representative Weston
I'm here in my office alone
representative bellew
here in Home Alone
representative Burroughs I'm here my
and lastly representative McAleer
um I'm here my wife's here but soon to
leave
all right uh that's the role Mr chair
and uh it's 18 present
all right great uh time being 904 we'll
open up the public hearing on House Bill
uh uh each 299 it's our HP 299
from the prime sponsor representative
patusek good morning representative
patusa good morning chairman hi and good
morning ladies and gentlemen my
colleagues on the Commerce Committee
um I'm here to introduce House Bill 299
and requested the insurance department
this Omnibus type deal will make changes
to several of the laws that regulate
property insurance
okay I have a little check sheet here
these changes will clean up the simplify
language in the statute on Motor Vehicle
liability provisions
they will allow the insurance request as
grounds for canceling a commercial
policy
they will modify the definition of
third-party administrators also known as
tpas
to include Property and Casualty PNC
insurance and remove Workers
Compensation Insurance
it will clarify that fools and rates
filed for information only we will be
held confidential
until they take effect
and to allow insurers to include the
fees for unanticipated costs while
calculating rates and clarifying
pro-rata premium earning for personal
Alliance policies
and finally it will remove quote
excessive Insurance unquote as an
exemption from the Consumer Protections
in RSA core 17-b
following me there are folks from the
insurance department to answer any
questions you may have and thank you for
your consideration of this legislation
if you have any questions for me feel
free to ask but I will uh pass on the
questions to the folks from the
insurance agency that are going to be
following me thank you for your
consideration and uh
that ends my testimony
uh great thank you uh Pam could you turn
very sorry about that I'm sorry I
you should be all set
okay yep there we go all right great uh
is there any questions for
representative
see none we will now call on the
insurance department and I'll start with
them
I'm pumping you up here Emily
okay
um
so uh Emily you're
yeah okay good morning can you hear me
yes we can I'm sorry my name is Emily
Doherty and I just confirming that you
did call me my uh cut out there briefly
on me yes I understand that happens when
I link you over so you're all set now
okay all right well thank you all right
thank you
um good morning again my name is Emily
Doherty I'm the Property and Casualty
attorney at the New Hampshire insurance
department
um as was previously noted this Omnibus
type bill will make changes to several
of the laws that regulate Property and
Casualty Insurance
I'll address each of the proposed
changes the bill proposes to add
paragraph labels to RSA 26418
which pertains accidents and financial
responsibility for motor vehicles and it
seeks to simplify the Law's language to
make the law easier to read
the bill also proposes two amend
Property and Casualty commercial Lines
cancellation statute to add cancellation
at the request that they start as a
basis of cancellation
this proposed change to make the
commercial Alliance cancellation statute
consistent with the cancellation
statutes applicable to the personal
lines Property and Casualty Insurance
that already exists in addition the bill
proposes to include all Property and
Casualty third-party administrators
within the third party administrator
statute rather than just workers
compensation third party administrators
it also seeks to simplify the wording of
the statute
the bill also proposes two men 400 RSA
400 a15-f which pertains to form and
rate filings to clarify that forms and
rates
file for informational purposes remain
confidential until effective
um
the bill proposes to amend 4 12 15 to
clarify that fees for unanticipated
costs may be recovered it also clarifies
the law relative to premium earning
patterns and the return of unearned
premium and personal lines lastly the
bill proposes to remove the excess
Insurance exemption from the
cancellation non-renewal statute RSA
417b
those are my comments on the bill I know
that although Attorney James Fox the
property Council director for the
Department is listed as going to provide
testimony today he will not be doing
that and that concludes my testimony
thank you thank you
okay so I can assume you're telling us
everything that Jim would also have told
us exactly yes we do have a question
representative Houghton
good morning thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming to testify before
us uh you kind of went over this quickly
and I'd just like to double check in
several places workers compensation has
been stricken and property and casually
casualty has replaced that language
could you just remind me as to why that
has happened here
um this is in the third Mark third party
administrator
um statue and this just before the third
party administrator statute just
um only included workers compensation
third party administrators and this
makes it so that it will include all
third party administrators including
workers compensation third party
administrators for Pro for Property and
Casualty Insurance lines thank you sure
okay none uh
and uh okay Jim you got yourself up
there good
so um inviting up Jim Hayden
and I have no idea what his position is
because he's signing up at
okay
so close but yet so far I've unmuted
myself
okay okay
so uh
Mr chairman members of community Jim
Hayden on behalf of State Farm
I signed up uh in support of this bill
but
I realized in signing up that I had
missed the opportunity to provide
testimony on the website so I just am
now doing it here because I do want to
testify on subsequent bills I just want
to make sure I could raise my hand and
be heard so uh thank you it seems I can
do that thank you very much
okay I guess everything's working fine
then okay
all right is there any other discussion
uh
uh I guess nobody has any questions for
you uh anybody else would like to weigh
hey
I guess we're all set all right
um see no more interest uh the
uh so I'll close uh before I close the
public hearing uh the sheet has eight
people in support nobody opposed and one
neutral
I'm not sure a neutral
Eric Rathbun
okay uh with that we'll close the public
hearing
that was way too easy
okay uh well
so we're we're done until uh 17 minutes
9 30. so
uh I guess I left a little too much time
for that one but
yeah 520.
okay
John how much snow did you guys get out
there uh
uh so I you know we've been getting a
couple inches here a couple inches there
so it's it's it's
over a foot and a half it's sitting out
there just screaming at me why I haven't
gone skiing yet you haven't gone skiing
yet well since the storm started which
you know
and then Monday I was you know Monday uh
I had my County delegation and then I
ran off to get my vaccine and
and uh and then yesterday we were busy
here and we had another full day here
and yeah so tomorrow yeah we got 12
inches on the ground over here in Derry
yeah we only got like three inches
yesterday
but it was like real soft and just
pushing away nice and fluffy that's good
it's nice for me you don't have to break
Trail too much so I have my base that's
under there so it's good yeah definitely
uh either pink or green wax
I I have waxes I haven't had I haven't
put wax on skis and
in 30 years
well this is this is hard wax for this
situation yeah the hard way you gave me
that that hard white wax yeah yeah which
I have used yeah but but if you want to
go a little faster you can put some on
yeah I actually I used the lubricant one
the one that's got comes on with a
little roller you roll it yeah
basically the same stuff so
but it's our my problem is more more
when the temperature is Right close
around freezing it starts to stick to my
skis that's so that's really really neat
other one than that I have a nice thin
long ski so I go pretty fast
back in the old days we use clister
I haven't done that a long time no not
hardly
foreign
one
thank you
beautiful
foreign
sir
[Applause]
foreign
okay
well I should have known better how we
do that that one 15 minutes
probably this next one too
but
I was kind of conscious of overloading
too many bills
it's hard to time them all perfectly
you've been doing pretty well I think so
the fact that we can get all our bills
heard in seven days is it's pretty
miraculous but we really have a really
light low lighter than usual so
well that's for sure
people really did take into a in into
heart uh take to heart the uh suggestion
that we not put in
a lot of bills that probably need a lot
of work yeah
I just wish people would call us call me
ahead of time or talk you know talk
before they put these bills in
so uh
because we really don't have time to
amend bills yeah well it would be
helpful but
that's a really good idea though
right
yeah that's a really good idea you know
in September of a campaign year
everybody's out straight in October
um I think it's hard for them to think
that far ahead
I've never introduced a bill because
there are so many bills that I mean this
is I've been here for 17 years I'm gonna
say you've been around because there are
way too many bills that are introduced
every year
um I can co-sponsor but
um I think
it takes a lot of time to follow a bell
or to you know bring it forward and
really make it success and uh I'll give
that to I'll give that responsibility to
others and representative you're also on
the school board
yeah three meetings this week yeah in
Manchester that's a a big school board
all right so it's uh 9 31 so why don't
we open up the public hearing House Bill
520 in here from the prime sponsor
representative Bartlett good morning
representative Bartlett good morning Mr
chair and committee I have a little
introductory speech here
um this bill was it was requested by the
insurance department and it was really
to
um
get the laws in line with what practices
really are with the insurance companies
I know I've been getting my my documents
um from Liberty Mutual for years
electronically
um I'm introducing House Bill 520 at the
request the insurance department this
bill will allow for electronic delivery
of insurance documents by making changes
to existing existing statutes and
creating a new chapter e-delivery of
documents is becoming standard practice
but currently the statutes specify
in-person or regular mail only with the
changes provided in this legislation and
insured may give their signed consent to
receive any documents electronically
there are folks here from the insurance
department to answer any questions you
may have thank you for your
good great
does anybody have any questions of
Representative Bartlett
uh seeing none we thank you very much
and the chair will then invite uh
attorney Doherty to
present the bill through the insurance
department
uh good morning again once again my name
is Emily Doherty I'm the Property and
Casualty attorney at the New Hampshire
insurance department
um as some little background this bill
was
um is the same bill as Senate bill of
579 from last year
um that had passed in the Senate on
consent but then was tabled by the house
and the pandemic hit as a general
overview in large part this bill
addresses consumer demand to receive
insurance documents electronically
by allowing consumers who want to
receive insurance documents
electronically to do so
I'll now go through the different parts
of the bill the first part of the bill
proposes to amend the Property and
Casualty cancellation and refusal to
renew statutes to allow for electronic
delivery of cancellation and renewal
notices
the second part of the bill
seeks to amend the commercial
non-renewal statutes to eliminate the
requirement that ensure automatically
issue a non-renewal notice to
policyholders where the premium will
increase more than 25 percent while
keeping the requirement that the insurer
provides 60 days notice to the policy
holder if the premium increase is
greater than 25 percent
um
the last part of the bill proposes the
addition of a new statutory chapter RSA
420-q
which would be called electronic
delivery of insurance documents and
notices under the new statutory chapter
and insurer could deliver insurance
documents and notices so long as the
requirements of uniform electronic
transactions act which is RSA 294-e are
met and the recipient has consented to
receiving the interest documents and
notices electronically
um
I know that um once again property
accountancy director James Fox was
scheduled to also provide testimony on
this bill today and he won't be doing
that
um but those those are all my comments
and I'm willing to take any questions
thank you
we do representative Burroughs has a
question
sorry about that
um just uh one question thank you for
taking my question
um
when I send a bill on QuickBooks for
example I know whether a customer's
opened it or not and I'm wondering if
there's any thought to that kind of
provision so that you know that the
electronic notice has been received by
the customer
um the bill does propose that the um in
the in the proposed 420q that the
um
that the insurer has to have standards
that they're confident that the um
the party who's signed up to receive the
dog documents electronically has
received them um and there's standards
that they're supposed to follow under
the 420 queue
um
I'm not yes thanks very much
representative Abel Humane choir
yes thank you and thank you Emily
already for your uh for your testimony
um could you just say a little bit more
about the process by which an individual
uh consumer uh elects whether to get uh
it's a lot this information
electronically or or uh by mail I just
um
just the the insurance company would
have to show that they had obtained the
um insured or the party receiving uh the
electronic notices consent to receive
them that way
and they would the insurance company
just uh would also have to
um allow a party to go back to receiving
paper notices if the party expressed a
okay
boy Insurance Department's getting off
easy today
okay
uh so over the attendees oh now Jim hate
him again okay so I'm moving over move
you back Jim
you weren't signed up so I didn't that's
so this is the dead air when they're
being transferred over one from one side
to the other and good morning Miss
attorney hate him again oh you got a
background now you get to see you great
say link Winnipesaukee
uh I actually don't I think it might be
a Long Island Sound okay
I don't know I uh I grabbed it offline
so you don't have to see that I'm uh in
my kid's bedroom uh working remote for
my wife who's working downstairs so okay
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh Jim Hayden on behalf of
State Farm insurance companies
um and I signed on um online in support
of this bill
um this is an important goal for State
Farm because it is uh committed to
updating and modernizing
um the laws throughout the country uh in
general and particularly in relation to
e-delivery of documents because frankly
this is uh as Miss Doherty indicated
something that's entirely driven by the
customers because that is the way they
get their documents from many other
companies many other types of companies
and it really is the standard way that
they view information from all of their
uh all of their companies all of their
places where they buy business you know
it's it's very convenient for them
because it allows them access to the
information right in their hand where
they typically interact with the world
it allows them to store the information
uh in a way so that they have ready
access to it later on it saves them the
need to figure out when they get paper
whether or not they need to shred it
before they throw it away
or they saves them the need to store it
somewhere and let it accumulate in some
file draw that I think a lot of folks
have been cleaning out during this time
of being
locked at home
so for those reasons I testify in
support of this bill but I also wanted
to to note a particular provision that
Ms Doherty touched on and it relates to
the requirement of a non-renewal notice
in the event of an increase of premium
and as Ms Doherty noted the bills still
requires notice to the insurance excuse
me to the customer of a substantial
increase in premium but it allows the
insurance company to leave the words
non-renewal off the form because frankly
just because there's a substantial
increase in premium doesn't mean the
insurance company doesn't want to retain
that person as a customer they're just
notifying them of a substantial increase
in premium that information will be in
front of them it's not necessarily A
non-renewal so it eliminates a lot of
confusion that is really the results of
statutes that were drafted long ago and
State Farm again supports this aspect of
the bill and the changes and in general
we support this bill as a whole so thank
you Mr chairman and I will take any
okay is anybody have any questions
I must say getting a 25 increase sounds
like non-renewal to me but I understand
that
we want to be appropriate to how we
label the form so that people know that
we didn't really mean to scare you away
right it was an automatic when the
market changes yeah
representative Abel has a question
and and I apologize I probably should
have asked this uh to the insurance
department but uh as far as I can tell
this has nothing to do with billing
methods of building it's only notices is
that correct
um certainly the um
the uh excuse me I believe I believe
that the general delivery of documents
includes billing
okay
okay anybody else have any questions for
attorney hatum
see none we thank you very much thank
you you've been testifying anymore today
or should I move you off permanently
let me just look I think so
let's see I want to be
uh not the next one but 450. okay
all right so uh anybody else who's an
as you're all just listening in okay
great all right so if there are no more
questions
um
we have uh six in support no opposed and
and
I have a feeling we we have another
weight again okay till 10 o'clock
all right well another 15 minutes I
guess we've got plenty of coffee breaks
today
Mr chairman yes
um if you like
um we could try test drive the screen
sharing that I'm mentioned just to make
sure sure
okay so this is a presentation you would
want to make okay sure it seems it seems
that I have permission yes okay so
let's see how this works let me
I think the key to screen sharing is
making sure you don't have other screens
open that aren't really appropriate for
sure
you start there right and then desktop
let's go
okay
it work I I can see a license plate a
Nissan you and you blotched out the
license plate number too of course
maintain
privacy yes so that that does seem to
work and you want to just scroll the
next page just to make sure everything's
sure
I'll go backwards
or is that the last one yeah there you
how many how many slides not many
so
um it seems it works okay oh so I will
stop the screens here and George russos
has raised his hand
so uh it's because that's his car
I'm pretty sure he doesn't drive a
Nissan
okay George I've loaded you up to the
you have a question George
maybe he wasn't expecting to do that
he was just playing with buttons all
right I get it well
um I'm glad I tried it out because I'm
hoping to testify this afternoon thank
you Mr chairman Mr Vice chairman Mr
Hayden that was my car uh
thank you for using it and blocking out
the license plate I appreciate that too
so the way this works I guess is
Lindsay's not here to tell me uh I
raised my hair
and then I wait for about an hour and
then I see the thing about on Muni if I
want to and I and I click it is that how
it works so
um I I sent the unmute because there was
a little delay
um you're supposed to know that uh right
now you're you're in control of your own
muting you know numbers I'm it's one
less task for me to worry about okay I
know I'd like to say I can mute people
if I want to but I I try not to unmute
them without them sure sure no but I
didn't see the mute sign up but I'll
work on that between now and uh this
afternoon okay thank you for the
opportunity to speak
thanks Mr chairman Mr Vice chairman
Happy New Year
same to you same to you I wish we were
in person someday that'll happen yeah
all right well I'm gonna
uh stop my video and mute myself okay
yeah uh I'm gonna I'm gonna throw you
back over to attendees you and Jim I'm
gonna throw you back over to these
but generally I will I'm I'm getting
pretty good at it I'm moving I'll move
people up before I announce your name so
you know you'll see that it you when you
get moved over but that I um I try to do
it ahead of time so we don't have that
lag so I just need to learn where the
mute sign is when I uh after I raise my
hand
you have it on your screen right are you
CC okay so I I'm I'm less less uh
educated about a PC but sure I see on
the lower left right now I've got it
right so that's usually there and then
actually if you point on your screen
yourself your own screen if you move
your arrow onto your own screen
yeah oh I see got another view so that's
the second mute button and then a fairly
new computer like I do uh there's a bar
you know on our Macs and I assume the
PCS have something similar to a bar
which will the mute button will also
appear there so there are multiple
muting Roots great okay can you uh Mr
chairman can you forecast at all what
the hearings look like at uh I noticed
we've got uh at two o'clock you've got
House Bill 310 the auto repair
you and Jim really care about so I I
would say at this moment
um I do not have it because the list on
who's testifying stuff they don't send
it to me until 15 minutes prior to the
hearing because there are some people
who are a little doggy about I see okay
all right great well thank you you guys
are doing a great job Mr
Vice chairman Mr chairman it's been a
pleasure to
follow all these hearings
it's very entertaining all right that's
great yeah there's nothing better
all right I'm signing off thank you
I'm just going to move I'm going to move
you over George
change your oh you're now going to be an
attendee so you don't have to do it
anymore
okay
I'm gonna do the same thing to you Jim
foreign
hunt
Chris yeah hi Chris uh yeah I'm reading
this uh the next bill I think it is uh I
hope we're getting I'm I'm uh I have to
uh admit to ignorance here and it seems
like there's three or four different
references
uh 501c3 50 something M5 and so I hope
that somebody that's going to sit down
and explain this legislation to us gets
gets at least me up the stream I I
it's a charitable I don't know about
charitable gift giving and annuities
stuff so
I'm just going to keep my mouth shut but
but I'm just warning you ahead of time I
want to be able to understand this a bit
better than whatever
Chris did you print out the example that
was sent by representative infantine
um no I don't know where he sent it he
said emailed it so um
you might want to look at that and he's
Amendment all right I I had I haven't
read Will's uh memo I don't know
what well that would help you prepare
for it yes but I get I have four email
accounts and the one I use the most
we've talked about that over and over
you've got to get in touch with the
clerk so that only one get you gets used
all right Chris just follow our lead
I will I mean I'm just warning everybody
I don't want to be uh you know I
probably won't say a word but uh just
warning the chairman that I'm
right at this point in time I'm I'm in
the dark
okay
fair enough all right uh so let me go
over here
and
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 527 and hear from
the prime sponsor will inventine
good morning Mr chairman uh members of
the committee I'm going to be with you
folks for the next hour and 15 minutes I
will try to make it extremely painless I
am very apologetic as to what happened
with House Bill 527 I submitted this to
OLS a few months ago and it was not
noticed uh by my constituent until like
Friday that it really wasn't written as
presented and it was actually a bad Bill
as initially presented house bill 527.
so I've been working with the Department
of Justice Tom Donovan I've been working
with um
my constituent and we've made a number
of changes I will give you a brief
overview of what this bill is about but
first let me introduce myself my name is
Will infantine of state representative
from Manchester award six which is
Hillsboro 13. I've been at the licensed
insurance agent in the state of New
Hampshire for 32 years
um I do not
um I'm not licensed nor do I sell
anything to do with any kind of
annuities
um but let me explain how I think most
of you know how some of these things
work uh you will place certain money
into an account with either a charity or
a an insurance company and they will
give you a contract that states you will
receive a certain amount of money back
every month for a certain period of time
until it either runs out or it could be
you know until until your death and
those are very well regulated Actuarial
tables are put together to make sure
that everyone understands exactly what
money they're putting in and what they
get back in return
most of them are guaranteed by insurance
carriers who have lots of money because
one of the most important thing we want
to do here when we we the government
sells any kind of or approves any kind
of an annuity is to make sure that there
is enough money to pay the individual
you signed a contract you put money in
you expect money out
um and and um
that's you know the way the way it's
supposed to work
um I Mr chairman can you see me you're
Frozen and I just want to make sure I am
not frozen okay very well you were just
being being really cool there
um
yes so um so what the the there are
certain charitable annuities there are
allowed you take a large Hospital which
might be a 501c3
um Mr Herbert and um
you want to be able to donate some money
to that hospital yet get some money back
the difference between a regular annuity
and a charitable annuity is if I'm going
to go out and buy an annuity I'm going
to check out every insurance company to
make sure I get the best deal for the
money I'm putting in for the longest
period of time whether it's a short
period of time and a longer a better
monthly return or a smaller monthly
return in a longer period of time but I
can make that decision on a charitable
one you're basically making a decision
to take less I'm going to take less per
month for the money I'm putting in so if
I'm putting in fifty thousand dollars to
this charitable annuity I'm going to
take a little less back per month but
some of the extra money
that's going to be left at the end I'm
going to give to the charity in a
response and as a result of that I'm
going to get a tax deduction which is I
want now I want my tax deduction now and
the charity gets some money
however to do that we want to make sure
that that charity has enough money to
fulfill the contract so we make sure
they have three hundred thousand dollars
in
liquid assets that are unrestricted and
all these other things
that's a great idea it's a super concept
we are not changing that law The
Proposal here is to say what do we do
for small Charities a group of hockey
teams a a group a a non-profit uh um
Charter School
um any kind of other small charity that
many of you may volunteer or donate to
something that's going to help help
um kids with special needs or any of
those type of things but they don't have
that three hundred thousand dollars in
restricted cash they can't do this so
the goal here is very simple
to allow smaller Charities to be able to
do the same thing
however the requirements are they only
have 25
000 in restricted cash but because we
want to make sure that they can pay this
contract they have to go find an
insurance company to pack it
okay so they can't just do it on their
own like some of the bigger Charities
can
they have someone else an insurance
company to back it and then that charity
gets that that difference between uh as
I said the example
you have you're taking a lesser return
on your investment and the charity gets
that money
that is simplistically what we want to
do here we're not changing the existing
law to cut into the Charities that have
ability to do this if they have over 300
000 restricted cash we're not trying to
um do anything that is not
I'm going to protect the investment of
the individual I talked to the insurance
commissioner yesterday they understand
that they would be still in charge of
these insurance companies
um that would be backing
um these charitable annuities
there is an example a financial planner
by the name of Steve Matthew has signed
up to speak he will be explaining the
example that was sent and how it works
Tom Donovan from the Department of
Justice
um has some questions
um that I've been trying to fix in these
amendments with OLS
um instead of the original Bill if
you've looked at it folks it kind of
groups everything together and that just
muddied the water instead we've created
an entire new section Roman numeral six
just for these smaller annuities it's as
simple as that I'd like to make it so
it's perfect
so there's no questions there's no
arguments everyone is protected and it
just allows for other smaller Charities
to do this this is not a novel idea this
is allowed in a number of states
um I'd be willing to take any questions
but I do know that Tom Donovan from the
Department of Justice will weigh in and
I also know Steve Matthew will weigh in
and hopefully answer any of your
specific questions I am not a financial
planner
I am over my head on the really in the
weeds thing on this one and that's why I
will allow those folks to speak but Mr
chairman keeping things quickly as I
always try to do for your very busy
committee I would be happy to accept any
questions
okay we do have a question from Anita
Burroughs
yes uh thank you for taking my
question
you may be able to
want to defer to Tom Donovan just just
quickly
um the it sounds very reasonable I like
the bill my only question is why did you
come up with the one that the charity
had to be in operation for one year
because that that kind of scares me
because uh there are a lot of small
Charities that come along and are flaky
and and are gone very quickly
representative
um I wanted because of that exactly that
comments that are flaky and come and go
we wanted didn't want someone to quote
unquote create a charity today and then
started then try to do one of these
things we wanted someone to be in in
business for a number of years as a
charity to prove themselves now if you
would like to increase that uh I'm not
going to have any problems someone
should be in business as a charity for
three years or something uh to prove
their uh worth I have no issue with that
representative thank you very much
okay any other questions for
representative infantine
uh seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you Mr chairman I
um
I guess what I'm going to call up Steve
first and then and then you Tom so you
can tell us what you what you really
feel about it so uh so Steve Matthew is
uh
um you're recognized to testify
thank you and good morning to all of you
um I my primary business today is taxes
I'm an accountant and do uh income tax
preparation but I do also own an
investment advisory I say planning
practice as well I have served on the
board of numerous uh Charities and
charitable organizations over the years
uh most recently the New Hampshire
Legends of hockey I was instrumental in
forming uh three different charities the
Saint Catherine School charitable
Foundation the St Joseph's Junior
Regional High School charitable
Foundation as well as uh a few others
and as well as many private Donor
advised funds for uh individuals who are
higher net worth individuals uh the
purpose of the bill is really to to help
some of these smaller institutional
Charities like for example the Saint
Catherine school or the New Hampshire
Legends of hockey or friends of Central
Hockey to raise money and one of the
tools that's uh that in our work with a
lot of senior citizens is they they
would like to find a way to make gifts
that that could benefit them but at the
same time uh benefit their small
Charities and so uh I gave you an
example and I don't know if you all have
that example in your hands but basically
I would just want to run through quickly
what it means what it looks like and how
it works in essence here we took a 70
year old individual I show it with a 100
000 donation well this individual would
get a 4.7 percent distribution for the
rest of his life do any of you know
where you can get 4.7 percent on your
money today
guaranteed all right and the fact is it
doesn't exist but in a charitable gift
annuity what they're in essence doing is
they're taking this and they taking the
Actuarial value of this individual and
they're paying it out over his life
expectancy now the difference is if they
were to take that same hundred thousand
dollars and go to a commercial insurance
carrier on their own they'd get
approximately 5.4 percent so to be
getting more money but they're willing
to accept a little bit less here and the
reason is and I'm going to go down on
the screen to the reason is because
they're going to get a 36 000 tax
deduction on this gift
because that's the net present value of
the remainder interest that would be
left to the charity now if we implement
this bill what happens is uh the charity
would then have to go out no if it's a
if it's a very large charity and they
were issuing this themselves uh that 36
000 would basically be frozen there and
they wouldn't be able to touch any of
that money until such time as that
individual died
and with the small Charities you're not
helping them a bit by doing this because
they can't even issue it unless they've
got 300 000 unrestricted cash so what
the bill does is it basically does two
things but a large Charities it allows
them to commercially insure it which
would allow them the ability to take
that residual value and use that either
for current use or put it into their
endowment funds and it would do the
small the same thing for the small
Charities as well now uh Tom uh Donovan
had raised some issues which I think are
very valid uh it said well
um uh you know some of these larger
Donor advised foundations do this uh do
charitable gift annuities now and the
answer to that is uh yes some of them do
a lot of them do not a lot of them don't
simply because they don't want to be
dealing with the uh Actuarial work and
the and the administrative work that's
associated with administering charitable
gift annuities all right so if we bring
the insurance companies into this which
uh are that's all they do is issue
annuities all day long uh then what
we're doing is we're basically taking
the risk off of this charity we're
allowing the charity to take advantage
of this right away and to have a
residual balance that they can spend
right away because they're going to in
this example I gave you uh the
approximate cost of the commercial
annuity would be 69 000 to fund that
forty seven hundred dollars a year for
the rest of the life of that 70 year old
all right they'd have Thirty one
thousand dollars that they could
immediately expend for their benefit
so that's the purpose of what we're
proposing here I want to give small
Charities the ability to raise money and
to get into uh and to build their their
endowments up if that's what they're
questions
anybody patients in the committee um I I
have a question yes sir representative
yes uh Steve nice to see you again I
don't know if you recognize me I do
Chris
um just a quick question does the small
charity does that have to be a 501c3
the the donor well the small charity
would have to be a 501c3 yes or if it's
a Donor advised fund they're basically a
a subgroup of a 501c3 so the answer is
in all cases yes in one way shape or
form they're going to have to be
affiliated with a charitable
organization that is a qualified charity
thank you uh very much for participating
uh okay representative Fargo next
the insurance company get paid gets paid
for this and how much of the um
how much they make when they help these
charities
create these annuities
yeah let me separate that into two
pieces uh the insurance company is
basically managing money and then they
they're managing the Actuarial risk tip
the typical insurance company is working
on one to one and a half percent spreads
of the of the assets under management uh
which is it was netting to them over a
long period of time uh and then if they
pay out a commission to an insurance
agent on these immediate annuities
typically they're paying insurance
agents today somewhere around one and a
half percent uh Commission on the on on
the sale of these things if they if they
ran it through it through an insurance
agent
any other question
all set yeah okay uh representative Abel
yes thank you very much for you for
testing uh for testifying uh I'm glad
you mentioned risks uh risk because
that's where what my question is
um I wonder if you could tell us what
the risks are for each of the parties uh
I mean the worst case scenario I suppose
um for the donor for the uh for the
charity and for the insurance company
and I don't know if there's anyone else
in there but I want to make sure that we
understand that fully what kind of risk
each one is taking in this kind of
transaction
sure
anytime somebody buys an annuity whether
it be a charitable gift annuity or
whether it be a straight annuity with an
insurance company uh the basic risk that
they have is the ability of the payor to
complete the transaction as promised and
so with charitable gift annuities right
now typically the only companies that
are the typically the only Charities
that issue are the very large ones with
uh millions of dollars in assets and the
reason for that is they have to have the
ability to make those payments and
guarantee those payments over long
periods of time in the case of the
insurance companies that's the business
that they're in managing risk and any
business that's licensed in the state of
New Hampshire for example any insurance
company in the state of New Hampshire uh
is required to join the New Hampshire
Insurance guarantee Association and if
one should fail basically the others
have to make good on the obligations of
the one that failed up to a hundred
thousand dollars uh per account so
um there's a certain amount of
guarantees that are built in whenever
somebody buys uh an annuity from an
insurance company but when they buy from
a charitable gift annuity there really
aren't any guarantees other than the uh
Financial wherewithal of that particular
charitable organization in this case
what we're doing is we're we're actually
adding uh we're adding safety a safety
margin because when we have the
insurance guarantee associations that
are at least providing for a portion of
the risk guarantee we're actually
putting the the purchasers in a better
position than if they're buying outright
from a a large charitable organization
that's solely relying on their own
okay
uh representative Bartlett I don't care
thank you Mr chair
um
um so what happens if
the charity is no longer it it's it
we're talking about a charity that's
only been
um in operation for at least one year
so if the charity goes away and this
annuities in place what happens to the
paths
in in this particular example if we're
allowing an outside carrier to fund this
thing then the individual would continue
to get their payments streamed uh
forever because in essence what we're
doing is we're we're subrogating that
risk to a commercial insurance company
and so whether the donor gets their
money right the donor continues to get
their payout
okay can I ask another question thank
you
um so the donor gets their money
the charitable organization gets all the
money up front is that correct well what
they're getting is the the original the
original donation comes into the charity
up front but in order for them to be
able to issue that promised annuity they
have to immediately within five days
under this bill purchase that annuity
from a commercial insurance carrier so
it has to go out the door immediately
to a commercial insurance carrier
so for the charity okay I'm sorry I'm
missing yeah the charity is then left
with the residual balance
so if you you look at the example that I
had sent up to you the residual balance
uh the the present value of the
remainder interest on the on the initial
purchase is 36 000 but then we have to
go out and buy an annuity that's going
to cost 69 000 to fund that to the
individual so they're only left with 31
000. so the charitable organization is
only left with a small percentage now
this this percentage changes depending
on the age of the individual that buys
the annuity the older they are the
greater the residual balance the younger
they are the less the residual balance
one more question another question being
Claire so
the board of this charitable
organization needs to be
pretty well informed in my and having
been on many boards
thinking that many members would
understand how this would take place
is that fair that is absolutely fair and
I would agree with you completely the uh
the value that that happens now is that
if you have and there are financial
advisors throughout the state and all
over the country that are literally
doing this they're advising their
clients to set up you know who who are
charitably inclined to set up these
types of things and basically those are
the people that are going to bring to
and educate the various boards as to a
way that they can raise funds for their
organization uh and do it simply and
cost effectively
so it's going to be it'll be you know
there'll be financial advisors that will
basically consult and for the most part
most of the boards that I know of most
of the non-profit entities in New
Hampshire and all the ones that I've
worked on is usually always either an
accountant a financial advisors or some
Financial person serving on those boards
and so it would behoove them to have
somebody of that nature who understands
these things working with them
one more question one further question
yes I'm sorry
um
I can see you know if you're talking
about a church
you have a pretty good chance of getting
a good Board of Trustees that may have
that expertise
you are on the Hockey Association board
but if you weren't there who on that you
know I'm not asking personal questions
but
um would there be somebody else on on a
on say the hockey board that would
understand
this kind of transaction
uh many of the boards that I've worked
with uh for example I worked with Opera
New Hampshire we had a couple of lawyers
on that board we had uh you know
different people that were financially
Savvy or or had a basic understanding
and and and truthfully when you sit down
and you you draw this out to somebody
and if I were to put this on kind of
boxes and graphs it's really a pretty
easy concept to understand you know on
this particular chart I gave you there's
way too many numbers on it and I'm only
showing it because it came right off of
the uh uh the the the pension not the
pension but the uh uh plan giving Design
Center
calculator website and so I normally
wouldn't show that to anybody but
basically uh what we want to know is
here's what you get here's what the
charity gets and here's where the money
goes and here's how the money comes into
you and it's really a a it's not a
complicated thing even though the
workings obviously there's Actuarial
calculations that go into this and uh
those are the people behind the scenes
doing that kind of stuff
thank you all right
okay anybody else have any questions for
Mr Matthew okay see none we thank you
very much for your testimony
and uh I'll now invite Tom Donovan on
the charitable trust division of the
Attorney General's office
good morning Tom
good morning uh Mr chairman and um thank
you to you and members of the committee
for allowing me to speak today I'm Tom
Donovan I'm director of charitable
trusts at the Attorney General's office
and um as is usually the case we are not
taking a position on this bill it's a
policy matter for uh you and the
committee to be considering we do have
um questions
um and concerns we want to alert you to
as to one
paragraph of this uh proposal I think
that um uh representative infantine and
Mr uh Matthew explained pretty well what
the intent of of this is our concern um
um relates to it it's um it begins at
line 20 on the original Bill and then
line or line nine of the amended bill
and it's it's a sub paragraph two
um but let me back up first to say so
why
um do Charities issue charitable gifts
annuity uh at some point back in time
some development officer at some charity
thought this is another good way to
raise money for your charity as I get
older
um I get letters from my college
uh trying to get me to buy a charitable
gift annuity to help my college and to
help me in retirement other non-profits
do the same it's it's a good investment
or it's a good fundraising vehicle it's
a little complicated but uh
um it's a way to provide an annuity to
uh an individual and then also some
money gets spun off to the the
non-profit
um so why then is charitable trust
involved
um
the issuance of annuities annuities is
an insurance product and
um generally
if you're going to be selling an
insurance product you have to be
licensed by the insurance department
and so if you are I don't know Dartmouth
College or something you don't want to
have to deal with the insurance
department so uh bill got passed years
ago to say that
um non-profits that issue charitable
gift annuities don't have to get
licensed as an insurance company so long
as they comply with certain obligations
that they have 300 000 in reserve they
follow certain annuity principles Etc
and then every year they have to certify
that their annuity program continues to
abide by those requirements
and so long as they do that
um then they're free to issue charitable
gift annuities and they don't have to
get licensed by the insurance department
so the filing comes both to us and to
um the insurance department and we get a
number of these every year where there's
just a checklist of five or so items
that that this charity is complying with
this requirements with respect to its
charitable gift annuity program
and that's all set forth in RSA uh
chapter 403 e
this bill would amend 403e to expand the
opportunity for certain group of
Charities to offer charitable gift
annuities
and as I said we're not taking position
on
on that uh there is one this paragraph
two that I've uh raises concerns and so
now I'm gonna for a minute
leave the world of charitable gift
annuities and and bore you with
um another
type of of charitable donation
so
um
you have the opportunity any individual
has an opportunity to um
to set up a Donor advised fund there are
companies like Fidelity Schwab
uh even the New Hampshire charitable
Foundation offer Donor advised funds
what that is is like a savings account
for you
um to put a a pot of money away you get
your charitable tax deduction up front
and let's say you donate ten thousand
dollars to Fidelity charitable
um you then can call them up uh this
year next year 10 years from now and say
I'd like 10 000 of that if I if I give
it let's say I don't know a hundred
thousand I'll give 10 000 to the Opera
uh and then in a couple of years maybe
I'll give 10 000 to the hospital you
call them up and you can give them
advice on it and then you can give it
away now you you got the tax deduction
in year one which is good it's no longer
your money
you have an account at Fidelity
charitable or Schwab charitable or the
charitable Foundation
and you give them advice and for the
most part they'll follow your advice as
long as it's a 501c3 that you recommend
the money go to
so that's what a Donor advised fund is
the uh the sponsors of those donor
advice funds are themselves charities
um so Fidelity charitable is a 501c3
Schwab charitable is a 501c3 the New
Hampshire charitable Foundation is also
so you can do that and
um it's a convenient way as I say it's
almost like a savings account you have
but it can only be used for for
Charities that that you choose
now
some
non-profits also choose to open Donor
advised funds and that's what uh Mr
Matthew was talking about
so if you are um friends of Central High
hockey
and you're trying to raise money but you
don't feel that
um you could invest it well or
um uh you just want it to be safe you
might say that our endowment is is not
going to be held by us but we're friends
of of Central High hockey is going to
open up a Donor advised fund let's say
with the New Hampshire charitable
Foundation or or Fidelity charitable
and then
the friends group when they want the
money for their own activities can say
we we'd like to use this money for our
own programming and infidelity
charitable will cut a check back to the
charity that's how it works so it's like
what paragraph two I think is intended
to do is to allow these small
non-profits
that use a Donor advised fund for their
own endowment
like the St Catharines Foundation or
friends of Central Hockey
to offer this charitable gift annuities
the concern I have is not with them the
concern I have is that you got the Tom
Donovan Donor advised fund at Fidelity
charitable
am I going to go out and and try to sell
charitable gift annuities or offer get
people to buy them I'm not sure who
would but uh if somebody I'd say you
know I'm I'm part of fidelity charitable
which is a 501c3 uh I can issue a
charitable gift annuity
um and um the benefit of it will come
back to benefit the Tom Donovan
Donor advised fund I'm not sure that's
the intent
um and I have might have some concerns
about that
so I don't have a concern if
if the if it's a charity that holds the
Donor advised fund I have a concern if
it's an individual that holds a Donor
advised fund so that's probably more
than you wanted to hear I think that
there are probably ways that that this
could be worked out in in language but
but that's the issue and by the way the
term should be Donor advised Fund in the
bill it should not be Donor advised
Foundation that it's a term of art Donor
advised fund
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
great thank you Tom uh representative
Herbert has a question but
you did say you were pretty confused
about all this right Chris
yes but I mean I I've I've actually sold
a hundred thousand dollars
insurance policy so I'm not as confused
maybe as I make out but um
uh Tom
the last part of your uh
uh conditionality or whatever that your
observation is that you don't want
I mean I understand this is all a huge
the funding for this stuff actually
comes out of the tax base
because you don't have to pay taxes once
you give it out to the charitable by
definition you're in a non-profit
situation and that money can compound
however it does without taxes being paid
so that's the whole idea of charitable
trusts all that stuff and I'm not
against that but the but the uh the
security part of it is where I get
nervous because all of this Finance ends
up in a bank somewhere
and a lot of it is in debt and if you
run into a situation like we're in now
where there's uh the most secure
Financial paper is a treasury and it
pays nothing or virtually nothing
so it's becoming more and more difficult
for these chairs pensions charitables
all these guys to uh put enough money
aside in order to pay out what they
promised in the beginning so I have I
have that concern that it's it's generic
but the last part you talked about was
you want to make sure that somebody's
not going around
using this vehicle just to sell
uh annuities
because
that's where the security is coming from
is is an insurance company somewhere and
then and and behind the insurance
company are banks so this is all tied
together
and I have one more I have one question
and I I don't know if you know it the
answer to this time and that is how many
uh
non-profit
organizations are there in the state of
New Hampshire
uh so representative Herbert there are
so we have registered with us 11
000 charitable organizations uh roughly
6 000 of them are based here in New
Hampshire so I think your question is
there so there are six thousand of us
here and that's everything from your
local Little League all the way up to
your hospitals and Dartmouth College and
everything in between okay so so my
concern with the generic cons another
question
do you have any cons where are your
concerns in terms of risk
and and your last comment is that was
that a risk variable when you were
talking about who's selling it and who's
owning it uh no uh my concern is is that
I want
um people who are giving to a charity to
be
um that that the the charitable portion
of it get used for charitable purposes
that's my concern the insurance
department would be concerned that the
buyer of the annuity gets paid
um and and so your other questions about
risk representative Herbert would be
best answered by the insurance
department
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question Tom I'm going to ask you the
same question that I I asked the
representative previously and actually
it's a two-prong question one do you
have concerns about the fact that under
this a charity could be in business for
just over a year and secondly do you see
how often do you see uh young Charities
let's put it uh um go out of business
after a short period of time in New
Hampshire
yeah that uh representative Burroughs
that's an interesting question
um
I don't have any specific numbers to
give you obviously
um newer Charities are more likely to
fail
uh than more established Charities but
uh we get a long time Charities that
that fail as well I it it a lot of it
just often it depends on the strength of
the board
do you have a problem with that one year
number do you think that should be
higher yeah I'm not going to comment on
uh representative Herbert do you have a
yeah okay let me put your hand down
you're muted crisp and I'm going to take
put your hand down okay you did okay
okay
for attorney Donovan seeing none we
thank you very much Tom and I see that
uh
Steve would like to come and offer up
the Last Words which he has time to do
so I'm going to bring him back in
and uh
um here here what he has to say
so to wrap it up Steve you got
uh
I'm sorry uh Tom Donovan did an
excellent job in raising a really good
issue
uh which is about small individuals who
set up their own and then all of a
sudden they're out selling charitable
gift annuities I just want to reiterate
the fact that even if they did the money
goes immediately to the large charitable
organization who is who is backing their
Donor advised fund so if it was a
Fidelity charitable if it was the
American endowment Foundation it was a
Renaissance Foundation whatever it is
that donor advice fund money goes
immediately to that organization that's
item number one number two uh all of the
distributions or grants that come out of
that donor advice fund must go to a
qualified 501c3
so that after the individual raises
money for his or her foundation they on
a personal level have no access to that
money ever again and when you set up a
donor advice Foundation you also cannot
benefit from that personally in other
words you can't be an insurance agent
selling it to yourself or setting up a
commercial annuity for yourself you
can't be in any way benefiting as
registered investment advisor on the
account uh I mean than just speaking as
a registered investment advisor my wife
and I have an account uh our own donor
advise Foundation set up at Fidelity
charitable uh we get nothing off of that
other than the fact that we're making
charitable donations each year and then
we you know we actually aggregate our
charitable contributions we might give
000 in one year to take full advantage
of our our tax deductions and the next
year women might not give anything to
that foundation and then ultimately in
any distributions we make to our
charitable to our church or whatever
come out of our foundation it doesn't
matter to us we never have access to
those funds again so while I understand
uh
New Hampshire attorney general Donovan's
uh position
um I don't think that it really matters
because again there's no personal
benefit other than the fact that the
Steve Matthew foundation of the Tom
Donovan Foundation is now making a gift
to the Opera New Hampshire or to the
Palace Theater or to whatever so I don't
think that's an issue so
at this point I'll shut up and if any of
you so I guess my question see it's
assuming that this uh concept right I
mean I certainly am familiar with this
product
um
assuming that this is around another for
small ones I mean because I the ones I
know are all big parody so but for so
this idea of having small Charities put
this uh create this I assume this is not
you know other states have done this so
have other states put in some kind of
safeguards or some kind of bumpers to
ensure that this this is not abused yeah
I I've reviewed the legislation of of 12
different states and and basically it's
it's it's almost word for word what came
out of those other states
so there are right now 48 out of the 50
states that offer this type of ability
for commercial insurance with regard to
the specifics of the Donor advised funds
uh being included in that I I truthfully
don't know because I haven't looked to
see whether any of them included it I
just put it into hours as an
afterthought because of the fact that uh
these are there are a lot of them and
some of the ones we work with that have
established these things and I see this
as a way to help them grow into larger
things I know right now we've grown the
Saint Catherine school from zero up to
it's probably somewhere around 180 190
000 right now uh the saint Marie's uh
three years ago Saint Marie's church we
were only at uh somewhere down around
000 we're up over half a million now so
they could issue one on their own if
they wanted to but still they're not
interested in hiring the actuary real
support they're not interested in the uh
the maintenance of these things and the
risk that's associated of having people
on their board who can manage those
funds for them and do what has to be
done so
um but but
that's that's kind of where I'm coming
at it I think perfect sense you know
what you're trying to do is makes
perfect sense but
um how about the one year did all the
other states who have have the the
non-profits existed for one year
uh I there are some that are one year
there are some that are five years there
are some that are three years it's all
over the place
right okay
so I throw out one year but you know if
you were to go three years I'm okay with
that doesn't matter to me I don't think
it's necessary to go five years the key
is whether there's an ongoing intent I
know like for example with the the small
ones that I work with uh friends of
Central Hockey we're we're interested in
building that up long term to continue
to support that organization years into
the future and if Central should cease
to exist there's a there's an intent
there where that would be immediately
transferred to another high school
hockey program somewhere depending on
what the successors are uh and the same
thing holds true if the diocese should
close down St Catherine's school or or
Saint Joseph Junior High School same
thing we've got a succession plan in
place under that Foundation where those
assets could be transferred to a
comparable organization
right well I certainly that's obviously
a terrible trust major major mission is
to take care of those who who wind down
and make sure the monies are are
appropriately uh yeah just to an
appropriate charity that's right but I
would have to say that most of the
orientations that I know that do this
um are large ones and I think a lot of
schools I mean I think the first one I
knew about was Deerfield Academy and you
know they have a huge endowment and and
uh so it's usually very large ones who
have uh the whole fundraising Department
who's you know people who are that's all
they do is go knock on doors and try to
raise money so uh it's the idea of the
little ones a little scary
um however having said that I am
treasurer of the wrench historical
society and we did uh receive a half a
million dollar Grant I mean you know
someone in their estate in which
immediately I you know I put that off to
having having
um an appropriate Financial uh entity to
manage that uh and manage that fund so
uh but the same time it's um it's a
little this the idea is it's a little
scary and you want to make sure that
um I I think it's a Rich Man sport you
know it's only it's all for people
who've got who need who've got so much
income that they they can afford to put
cash away and and get the tax deduction
um so so but at the same time we want to
make sure that we uh make sure that that
nobody gets tempted to to abuse this
well I think by and large you're correct
I mean the the vast majority of the
people that are purchasing the
charitable gift annuities are people of
means and most of them are in the at
least a 22 federal income tax bracket
and they're they're paying the New
Hampshire interest and dividends tax so
I I think you're correct uh to address
uh uh representative Herbert's point
from a tax standpoint uh the uh this
actually by by building up a lot of
these charitable organizations you take
a lot of pressure off a lot of local
communities and governments because uh
if you look at who delivers uh Justin
just in Manchester for example you know
you've got Catholic Charities uh
delivering you know billions of dollars
of services every single year that
otherwise would probably have to be
supported by government to some extent
so I you know I think there's you know
it's a double-edged sword yeah yeah
there might be an initial year loss but
in future years if people are building
up these endowments and these
organizations it certainly is to the
benefit of the communities that they
serve
fair enough okay everybody all set any
more questions seeing seeing none uh we
okay thank you and we will close the
public hearing
and uh well not a lot of people signed
up on this one that we have one person
supports no not a pose and one was
neutral
uh with that I will close the public
hearing
and we're right right on time for our
next one I think
all right okay
all right relative to motor vehicle
okay
uh all right so this is your Will Bill
will this is also your bill right yes
yeah it's all lined up here okay well
then you're
you're on all right you can hear me Mr
chairman yes I can thank you this is
representative will infantine from
Hillsboro 13 which is Ward 6 in
Manchester
um I am submitting this bill on behalf
of the New Hampshire insurance agent
Association where I served as a board
member the president uh at one point I
am now on our national board so
unfortunately I do too many things for
uh for no money
um but that's okay I like that I don't
mind volunteering put this under no good
deed goes unpunished 32 years ago when I
received my insurance license the
insurance uh limits minimum insurance
limits are the same as they are today
New Hampshire is one of only two states
that doesn't require mandatory auto
insurance and I'm okay with that because
the numbers bear out and I don't want to
get into a discussion about that but I
must say for a state that doesn't have
insurance requirements auto insurance
requirements we have more people have it
than in other parts of New England that
it's all mandatory because we have some
they called underinsured and under
uninsured and underinsured motorists so
if you get hit by someone like I did by
a drunk driver at 11 o'clock one morning
um who didn't have insurance my
insurance took care of it I got to
manage it and my car was taken care of
and it didn't cost me anything uh it
cost my insurance company didn't cost me
anything
and uh it didn't affect my record but as
a result of only having uh being one of
the only two states that no longer
requires auto insurance
um you we do two things if you get into
a auto accident where you caused damage
or liability to some in private
individual and you do not have insurance
coverage the insurance department says
You must get insurance before you get
your license back you must have it
because you've already caused an
incident so you have to have it many of
you have heard about it with uh DWI is
there anything called they called an
SR22 form where you have to have this
coverage we also tell people who get
their first car and they Auto and they
say Hey you know I'm gonna get my first
car I want to get insurance I want the
minimum Allowed by New Hampshire law
that's what we have right now these
minimums are you know as outlined in the
bill
um they're very low
um and my opinion is we are giving a
false sense of security to someone to be
able to say look we need you to get this
mandatory Insurance because you're
forced to because you didn't have
because you had an uninsured claim
before
or whether you're just starting out and
you just want to or you want to get
insurance and you're buying the minimum
and I don't think that's enough the 25
000 in in
um
coverage for property damage I don't
think every single one of you have
probably has a vehicle worth more than
twenty five thousand dollars you might
be a little irked if someone hits you
when they have the bare minimum
now in Maine
um has a much higher limit the same
limit that I am proposing now I this
goes under as I said no good deed goes
unpunished I didn't mean to cause a
Ruckus I just think that after 32 years
we should probably have insurance limits
up to where they should be
uh
I can't hear him but I see him
well you could well I only see the
square I don't actually yeah I don't see
his face no back into his face
uh yeah I can't hear him so how do I
make sure he knows we can't hear him I
can hear you fine oh there he is okay
there you are
I I don't know where I lost you Mr
chairman um
the bottom line is I just think there
should be enough coverage when we're
mandating people either have insurance
or we're offering them saying this is
the bare minimum it should at least be
able to cover
um what a normal car accident uh would
would entail the cost to increase this
is about 15 to 20 dollars a year
in the estimates that my office has done
for me so we're not talking huge amounts
um
but I I don't want to cause a big Ruckus
the insurance agents feel that it should
be higher uh if someone comes to my
office Mr chairman and says this is what
I want for coverage
um I want the bare minimum I have no
choice but to sell it to them by law I
cannot say no
now I do have them sign a waiver saying
I don't think this is appropriate we
want you to buy at least 100 000 for
occurrence three hundred thousand
aggregate because we feel that's
appropriate because we don't want to get
sued and we don't think that's
sufficient but
again if people people have a problem
with this I'm not going to rush my
Laurels onto the Insurance Agents
Association wanted to make their point
that we think it's too low and and we
get complaints a lot of times about
people saying they someone didn't have
enough coverage why doesn't the
legislature do something about it well
we're going to try to do something about
it
um and we think that uh Alaska and Maine
on both ends of the country have decided
that uh I'm right and they've increased
theirs many of the other states do not
have limits that I have proposed but
then again they all have mandatory
Insurance we're one of the few that
don't
uh happy to take any questions Mr
chairman okay yeah before I go I just
want to make sure I uh correct something
to understand
um
if you were to get into an accident with
someone who the other person said fault
and they are uh at the current level you
know the uh would you consider under uh
under insured
so even if the claim you're making is
going to be greater than what they are
covering then your policy kicks in for
the difference and it would be can still
treat it as a uninsured because it's
they're underinsured but it's considered
under uh uninsured and so you don't uh
your your policy can't be impacted
um if if that has to kick in that over
over and above if the other person's
policy is not adequate is that correct
yes yes and gnome from a liability
standpoint yes but if you don't have
uninsured motorist for property damage
or uninsured then your vehicle may not
be covered ability standpoint because
you know you have to buy when you buy
uninsured and uninsured motorists
there's two aspects to that one is a
liability and one is a physical damage
not everyone buys the physical damage
because it's a liability issue here but
uh it is true that I I
um my old sobs there's someone dating
back to 95 and in my 2000 I I don't buy
Collision because uh the car's not worth
anything right okay we do have questions
representative first
uh thank you Mr chair uh representative
infantine I have one question
um for you what is the if you know
what is the typical level of insurance
of the average driver in the state of
New Hampshire uh you're you're going
after fifty hundred fifty
[Music]
um
if you know what the average is could
you uh share that with us you know we
asked the insurance department when we
met with them in November and expressed
our desire to do this and they were
going to try to get us a number but they
were not able to figure it out by the
information they have so
um I would not be able to even Venture a
gas representative
thank you
thank you uh Mr chair
um you know that this is um a bill that
I'm going to strongly support
um we've got to get our limits up
um for mandatory limits
um
you are right oh well anyway that's all
okay uh uh representative McClure is
next
um thank you uh Mr chair
um a question actually my first real job
was as an insurance adjuster in Maine
and I was absolutely shocked when I got
to Maine and found out you didn't have
to have auto insurance but I can't
remember what
how it was settled so for example
um I get hit by somebody who doesn't
have insurance or doesn't have the
limits my uh uninsured voters coverage
kicks in uh in New Hampshire does the
insurance company subrogate against that
individual if or do they just wash their
hands and walk away
I think they make every attempt to
subrogate to be reimbursed for what they
had to pay out more often than not
sometimes these people really don't have
any other aspects
okay thank you
yes thank you very much and thank you
representative infantine
um my question uh may have been answered
but I I still want to ask you make sure
I understand
um when we um we heard a bill uh I
believe the last session that was to uh
change from allowing people not to have
automobile insurance they're requiring
um everyone and that did not go forward
of course
um but we heard a lot of testimony from
people who uh had been in situations
where their own they didn't have enough
Insurance themselves and someone else
hit them and so they they couldn't make
up the difference damage and so forth
um
that's my question my question my my
question is uh
um
will the will the will the increase that
you Advocate uh in your opinion uh
obviate the problem of uh I mean and uh
perhaps perhaps you could just I know
you spoke about it could you just say a
couple a little bit more about how you
came to those uh those limits
yes we kind of emulated what the the
ones were
um the higher ones which are again we
are emulating Maine and Alaska many of
the other states are very close to where
we are we're about in the middle
currently
um yes there's a lot of frustration when
someone has minimum coverage
um and it doesn't adopt you hit a one
car which hits another one you're
responsible for both cars and that
twenty five thousand dollars isn't going
to to be enough
thank you
uh you just blurted out again we'll
we'll see if you're there in a second
uh thank you Mr chairman representative
infantite Mr chairman I have three
questions may be recognized for three
quick questions rather than to ask you
uh Siri Autumn thank you representative
infantime can you tell us uh how many
years the current minimums have been in
place here in New Hampshire
uh representative other than the 32
years I've had my insurance license I
don't know how long after that that
we've utilized these same limits would
you be able to get that to us please yes
thank you number two um I'm wondering um
you have made reference to the other 49
states and New Hampshire being somewhere
in the middle
can you be more specific than that and
also uh part 2B uh what's the rationale
for emulating Maine and Alaska
rather than any other states and why
emulate
I will send you a list of the entire uh
country every all the minimum limits for
everyone I have a nice little chart here
so everyone can see where we are most of
them are 25 50 25 where we are
um uh why mean in Alaska we were looking
we didn't want to be more than anyone
else
so that was one of the rationale and it
was just simply to double what we had
which
um just happened to be Alaska and Maine
and number three would you restate once
again uh please
the uh rather I think you said rather
minimal amount and you may have even
Quantified this in terms of an estimate
uh a minimal amount in uh premium
increase to double the limits
yes this quote these were quotes for for
me so I'm a 57 year old male so it's not
going to be it'll be higher for others
understood it would have been 15 dollars
for my wife and I combined on a policy
it would have been 24 increase if I had
two drivers and two vehicles it would
have been a 35 increase
um
so annually correct because a lot of the
policies now are written for six months
so a rather minimal increase in the
amount of premiums to receive a
substantial increase in coverage correct
yes but I will offer one thing to you
because I'm I'm gonna I like being
honest about both sides of the coin here
every time you raise limits and you
raise prices you will have people that
will not be able to afford it so with it
there is a law diminishing returns
um so I I you know I was trying to be
very careful that you don't raise it so
much that we get those people that are
are at least getting coverage
voluntarily
not mandatory that we don't want too
many people to say I'm sorry this is too
expensive I'm not going to do it so
we're we're um
um sensitive to that as well
yeah Mr chairman my other remarks would
be better shared in I believe in
executive sessions so thank you very
much so yeah so well let me just follow
up on that you know when you were saying
these numbers incremental fifteen twenty
dollars that that's for for everybody in
the room here because I would venture
that nobody in this room has an SR-22
correct if you have an SR-22 it's not
going to be just 15 or 20 dollars more
no I for the DWI yes that is I wasn't
I remember and this was a very long long
time ago and when I was in Vermont and
uh uh my my insurance uh quadrupled
when they the the state of Vermont
decided that I had won too many speeding
tickets
so when your insurance is going to
quadruple anyway if you get a DWI that's
just basically oh this wasn't DWIs these
are purely speeding tickets on Route 91
because I was too far away from Maria
from everything else so I I I guess we
it will we need to know how how much it
really costs because the issue is not so
much for the average Joe to get these
higher limits because they're available
to them now they don't they don't need a
law to tell them that it really is a
good idea to you know to get these new
the 5100 all right it's really good 50
you know it's a good idea everybody
should have that okay and if it's only
20 you know you know the premium
increase is less that's fine that's good
that's that's we're doing a good job in
New Hampshire the issue is really the
people who don't want to buy it and the
SR-22 people and that now you've now you
not only this is like this is a double
penalty for not only getting that as
SR22 but you know you're going to you
know quadruple
their preview I respect what you're
asking and by Friday I will have a
cross-section of different quotes from a
single individual to someone with a DWI
to a teenager
um and and be honest with exactly what
the cost increases are and I will share
with you folks and if it's not to be
it's not if it's too much you feel it is
it's not to be that'll be fine Mr
chairman okay great thank you uh
representative meckler is your hand
still up from before or do you have
another question okay uh representative
my question so I think we'll answer it
but you know my concern is you I just to
be honest I've got two teenage daughters
one's driving right now
um one's coming up to be driving God
help me
and you know my daughter does have her
insurance on her vehicle but this
increase for a 16 17 year old they are
trying to do the right thing and if you
keep increasing this they not may not be
able to afford it so then they're not
going to have it if you keep increasing
these limits would this not then deter
these young people who are trying to do
the right thing by having a coverage
make it so that they can't even afford
it anymore
that is a concern we don't keep
increasing it I'll just comment that as
I said before we haven't done it in 30
years but I respect what you're saying
and I wouldn't want your daughters to
then choose not to have coverage so
that's why I'll present I should have
done it I apologize for not doing more I
will present to the committee by Friday
A A variation of different things and um
of what the price increases could or
could not will be
um under different scenarios and then
everyone can look at them and be better
informed to make a decision
because I don't want that to happen
either the last thing I want to do is to
have fewer people voluntarily choose to
get insurance auto insurance in New
Hampshire we wouldn't we wouldn't had to
put more pressure on have to have
mandatory because people dropped it okay
representative greeson you're up
uh thank you Mr chairman and I thank you
representative infantine uh when you
include these uh these samples the one
uh aspect of insurance and insurance
premiums that has not been discussed so
far has been the deductible and so when
you run your scenarios uh would you
please include
anything from a 500 deductible to a two
thousand dollar deductible or something
along those lines just to just to show
that your deductible can also uh change
the amount of your premium so while
you're you may you may double the
coverage but maybe you go from 500 to a
thousand dollar deductible and you're
now back down to where you were I know
you know what's what's the difference
maybe you can't come up with a thousand
dollars I don't know but that's just way
if it's the if it's the monthly amount
that's scaring people away then there
are ways of bringing that back down so
it's just just ask if if you would mind
including that in your scenarios not at
all it's very simple for us to do with
uh some a bunch of computer programs we
have in place so that's why I'm
confident I can get all this to you on
my Friday
and I will include different deductibles
okay uh we're now recycling through for
people who've already spoke so uh
representative Terry here first
yeah quick question uh Mr chairman uh
for you uh as a uh as a lifelong Pastor
in Theologian I would always be somewhat
embarrassed when somebody would raise
his or her hand and ask uh Pastor what
did what did you mean by the term super
lapsarian
because I had failed to Define it
um I do not wish to put you on the spot
I'm glad you're chuckling but for those
of us who are new to Insurance inside
baseball what is Sr uh 22 okay so the
SR-22 is if you had too many speeding
tickets ddui you're basically uh are
forced to have to buy insurance it's
basically it's a requirement you have to
buy insurance and it's issued by the
department of safety thank you
representative Bartlett you're next
thank you Mr chair of course the SR-22
is also a view of a DWI or you're an at
um but um just I I think we need to
address um representative Grayson's
request regarding deductibles that only
has to do with Collision coverage it
does not apply to liability
correct so that doesn't affect what
no worries good point okay
representative McClure
so your hand just keeps popping up how
does that happen
all right I'll lower it for you okay
uh and and I assume representative you
just haven't loaded your hand yet so I
guess we're all set thank you very much
will and uh we'll uh now invite the
insurance department uh uh Christina
certel uh Sotelo will uh uh be speaking
for the insurance department which is
um hello chairman thank you uh my name
is Christian citarella
I am the chief Property and Casualty
actuary for the New Hampshire insurance
department
note that the as you mentioned the
department is not taking the position on
this bill
um but I thought I would Avail myself in
case there are questions that uh you
might that the committee might have
regarding uh effects of raising the
minimum limits
um
uh I just want to mention that you know
the reason we don't take a position on
the bill is because from the perspective
of the insurance department this isn't
going to affect our day-to-day
operations we'll be able to enforce this
new law just as easy as we were able to
enforce the Old Law so
um
okay any questions I'm here
all right uh does anybody have any
questions for the insurance department
uh seeing none okay so I am now going to
invite uh people who are attendees and
foreign
and I'm also
promoting uh return Brittany shoot okay
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee Again Jim Hayden uh
representing State Farm insurance
company and speaking in opposition to
this bill
um I think that uh
this is the first time I've spoken out
against it so I'm not sure that I'm
creating any I've created any Ruckus
that's going on
um but I do want to share the
perspective of State Farm on these uh on
these this bill and these types of bills
um because I think it's important for
you to consider frankly I think
representative infantine did a fantastic
job of you know introducing the issues
that are associated with this bill but
in considering the context uh our bill
any bill that raises mandatory minimums
either in New Hampshire anywhere else
State Farm inevitably concludes that it
will do nothing more than raise the
number of uninsured drivers and
uninsured tax
even though New Hampshire doesn't have
mandatory automobile insurance in
general there are the people who are
required to have them have insurance
because of their driving history or
their accident history
um and those folks would be uh in effect
uninsured and would have issues relating
to
um you know uh whether living in New
Hampshire requires them to drive without
insurance without a license
in New Hampshire even though it's
against the law so for that reason
for those reasons we would oppose it
also in general you know the question
about minimums uh and levels of
insurance and coverages is really a
conversation that needs to happen
between the agent and its cost is his or
her customer
in other words you know that's their job
to in effect layout the the information
for the customer and I respective uh
representative infantine
um and uh it does not advise folks to
have lower limits than as presented on
this bill however that's a fair point
for him to make to his customers and
when they make the decision about what
type of insurance to buy and what types
of limits they need so with that comment
we oppose the bill and I will take
questions if asked okay we do have a
question representative Terry
hello sir thank you for your testimony
do I understand you to say that it
actually becomes a counterproductive
to raise mandatory minimums because of
the number of insurers who will actually
uh yes so the decision point is when you
buy the insurance I would rather say
it's when you
when you buy the insurance initially so
I suppose it's both when they drop when
they renew or when they or when they buy
it for the first time but inevitably at
that point more more people choose to go
uninsured so in an effort
to attempt to
provide additional coverage minimum
coverage for the insured which then may
very well have
a positive effect on a person who is
involved in an accident with someone who
is insured at the uh at the minimum
level
um but if that minimum were to be to be
greater and if the person was found to
be at fault who has the mandatory
minimum amount
um it would actually be better that the
person had the men the the lower
mandatory minimum and have the insurance
rather than not renew and have no
insurance where then the burden would
fall even in a would have a greater
impact on the not at fault drivers
Insurance having to go to uninsured
motorists and uninsured property damage
correct
uh represented respectfully I'm not too
sure I followed the that entire question
um but I I will say that State Farm in
general uh supports the premise that the
more insured drivers and more insured
accidents we have in New Hampshire it's
better for New Hampshire in general New
okay representative McCleary you have a
question for Mr Hayes yes I do thank you
uh chairman Mr Hayden so you don't want
to raise the limits would you think
differently if there was mandatory
Insurance in the state in other words
um if everybody had to have it would you
be in agreement or not an agreement to
to raise the limits
um State Farm would oppose raising the
mandatory limits if insurance was
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um did you say you have an estimate of
how much it would increase uh premiums
uh I do not have that estimate
um and you know there's many factors
that go into that
um but I don't have an estimate
currently
follow-up
uh is there something else we could do
with this bill for example on
deductibles as uh someone else mentioned
uh earlier is there something else that
could be done that would kind of balance
us out that would allow us to uh
have people with 50 000 in coverage but
uh at the same price as a twenty five
um
[Music]
whose opportunities exist they would be
better known to the agent than me uh you
know they're the ones who know how
various coverages and limits and drivers
and all the factors that go into the
prices and insurance and to the extent
uh the extent uh any concern we wanted
to explore those options I think would
be better left for the agent to discuss
them rather than you know trying to work
it out through this bill
fair enough
okay uh thank you very much for your
testimony
uh terrible Colin Brittany shoot shoot
good morning members of the committee my
name is Brittany Shu I am the bureau
administrator of financial
responsibility at the Division of Motor
Vehicles we do not take a position but I
did hear some conversation related to
the SR22 policies and with that I wanted
to highlight that line 16 and 17 of this
bill do not reference RSA
26420 and in that RSA of 264.20 it does
speak to the minimum
requirements of the 25 50 25
so if there is an expectation that the
SR-22 policy would follow suit with the
minimum insurance requirements I just
wanted to bring your attention to that
so thank you for your time and if
there's any questions I'll be happy
um to answer so let me get this right so
if we were to pass this would a uh the
SRT if someone had an SR-22 they'd still
have to get this because or they
wouldn't have to get on my assumption is
they would have to get these new limits
thank you for your question I so what I
think the clarification that um I would
be looking for that if the insurance
premiums were changing for the liability
that the SR22 minimum levels would
follow suit as well
they would yes okay that's what we're
assuming yeah okay
great any other questions
for Britney seeing none thank you very
much
uh I'll look to the attendees is there
anybody else who uh would like to speak
George you don't want to tell us what
happened when we tried to raise med pay
unmute
start video
you got it man oh thank you
that's that's enough for today
so I wasn't gonna
testify but I appreciate your allowing
me the opportunity
um uh I I I
have been talking to representative
infantine about the bill and uh uh
uh reluctantly I have to say that uh
I think our clients
would would
oppose the bill and and and uh let me
make a couple of points um uh my my
clients are the uh domestic insurance
companies New Hampshire Association of
domestic insurers uh and a large trade
Association uh called the American
Property and Casualty Insurance
Association I certainly understand uh
Will's point that uh in uh well over 30
years the limits have remained the same
at 25.50 and I think you will find an
interesting
um when we'll send you the list of
states and one point that I just noticed
that I hadn't noticed before is that
um
the under the bill the limit for
property damage liability would go from
25 000 to 50 000. I'd just like to
mention that that would be the highest
in the country
um in fact the highest uh presently in
the country is where we are right now
which is at 25 000. that's where the
property damage liability so question do
you do you really want to go
uh to that level
um again I think it would be helpful for
you to look at the at the limits that
other states do have we're kind of right
in the middle as well as representative
infantine said uh we all agree that
people if they can afford it should have
limits higher than twenty five thousand
dollars per person uh injured and fifty
thousand for the total liability
coverage for an accident but there are
many people who can't afford it and uh
the point has been raised and I I
certainly agree with it that that you
would basically disenfranchise a lot of
people from having insurance if you if
you uh mandated these uh these limits
and I leave it to you to decide what the
best policy is certainly uh
uh anyone who wants higher limits can
can buy them uh but they're not forced
to have them so thank you
so George the question I would have is
if if we were to raise the rate
um the law of averages in terms of the
fact that now you're forcing everyone to
have these higher uh minimums that
um would there would would that the
increased cost for those minimums versus
let's say the people who are already now
buying higher Insurance net rate now so
if we the numbers were here as well it's
only 15 or 20 dollars more to to double
your minimums would that number still
hold true or would uh these numbers
actually go down if more people are now
have the higher limits because the law
of averages would average it out or or
do we have any idea what would happen to
to these
that's a perfect question Mr chairman
for Christian citarella who you you let
get off without even asking him a
question
he's the actuary and that is an
excellent question I can Hazard a guess
but it would be a guess and and I also
think will volunteered uh to uh get you
some figures about what is the cost uh
of going of doubling the the minimum
limits and and I I don't want to give
Christian more work but I would think
you you might want to ask I can because
so Christian you're still on online uh
are you did you hear what my question
was
oh
do you mind re uh restating it yeah so
so we're in terms of the idea uh that
one of the argues of if you had things
that are mandatory then things should go
down because everybody is now people
were buying it who weren't buying it
um so uh vice versa the same question is
right now the discussion is that if you
were to buy a higher minimums right now
um it's only going to be like 15 or 20
dollars more for that 50 year old male
okay so the question I would have is is
if we mandate this uh that that uh the
minimums are now that higher limit would
that number stay at 15 or 20 would it go
down would it go up uh what would happen
to the the all those who who buy higher
higher limits now what would be the
um
probably wouldn't go down
um but I would uh first of all
there are a lot of assumptions there and
and it's hard to it's always hard to
come up with it with a point estimate
however when I did my own analysis with
the limited information that we have at
the department
and looking across you know not
separating out by age group just looking
across all premium sold
um considering the fact that rough like
some less than 20 somewhere between 10
and 20 percent of policies are at
minimum limits and so these these
changes wouldn't affect everyone
obviously
um
it at least in the immediate time frame
I I don't think it's
with all due respect to representative
infantine I think the s that estimate is
low for the average person who has
minimum limits
um I think it would be more in the 50 to
100 range increase per annu annual uh
policy however over time
there is something to be said about you
know
um
premium leveling out
now the question is
whether
you know having the higher limits
causing you know causing folks to go
without insurance to you know opting out
how does that affect
you know rates for everyone
in the work that I've done you know
almost annually we have a bill to make
insurance mandatory and so I do look at
you know first of all we don't have a
lot of folks that don't have coverage
generally speaking
um
we had you know it is well covered and
so
I don't think that the amount that folks
would save by having lower uninsured
underinsured motorist coverage
would be that noticeable over time
um
long answer to say that it's
likely going to be hit
it's going you know the effect will be
on the folks that currently are at
minimum limits
you know whether that number is thirty
dollars a year or a hundred dollars a
year probably somewhere in between
depending on the individual and um
and I don't see that changing much over
time
you say that's about 10 to 15 percent
is so that's my estimate of the
population George might know better but
the population that is currently opting
for minimum limits
okay
do you know that number George is that
10 15 sound right
it's it it sounds right yes but that's
just the other thing I'll mention is
that I did do a survey of just a handful
of the bigger
um insurers carriers in the state and
generally speaking it's pretty it's it's
pretty uh consistent that there's gonna
that if you do go from a 2550 to a 50
hundred
um you know uh liability
that the the rate is the the the
adjustment in rates is going to be an
additional 27 to 30 percent
on just the portion of Premium
associated with liability
and so generally speaking
the amount of Premium you pay for
liability and and that's bodily injury
or or property damage although the
property damage increase in in uh limits
is way it's a smaller increase but we'll
leave that aside for now
um the amount of Premium that is
associated with though with those pieces
of coverage make up approximately 25 to
30 percent of your premium so when you
take those numbers together
it comes to depending on the the company
somewhere around five to ten percent
increase in overall premium is is what
I've done in in my overview
okay you have a thousand dollar policy
that's how I came to the 50 to 100 okay
uh representative Burroughs do you have
a question for attorney russos or
which is citala
you all said okay uh thank you guys very
much and is there I see no more hands up
on either side panelists or attendees
so we will close I I guess before we
leave
um
so this Bill had six support uh seven
opposed uh one neutral and I would also
say this is a good time for all the
members of the committee to pull out
your auto policy and look at your
numbers you'll be very surprised what
you have okay well thank you all very
much and we're
we're ready to move into our final
hearing
and okay well you're on
all right thank you Mr chairman I'm
trying to click my video on but I don't
know what's working
um before I as representative will
infantine uh Hillsborough 13 hopefully I
have not worn my welcome out here today
I apologize for some of these complex
issues that I brought up and um I
appreciate your diligence this one's
going to be much more simple
it all it sounds uh pretty bad when you
look at it House Bill 518 relative to
rebates under the governing unfair
Insurance practices in the state of New
Hampshire we have extremely tight
laws regarding rebating we don't want
Shenanigans and games going on where
people are rebating uh giving Kickbacks
to on their insurance commissions or
giving out a car or motorcycle or things
like that to entice someone a group of
people to buy insurance from them so we
have very strict rules and those rules
are very strict for us as individuals I
cannot pay anyone a commission unless
they have a new insurance license
so what happens is we like to give our
commissions back to our employees people
10 15 people work for me they pay a
thousand two thousand dollars a year
for insurance I don't really need to
make you know 15 commission off my
employees as a employee perk I like to
give them their commissions back many of
our agents do that but if I have 15
people in my office maybe only 12 or 13
of them are licensed insurance agents
one of them may be in Human Resources
one might be in accounting one might be
a clerical uh and they don't have an
insurance license so legally I am not
allowed to give some of those
commissions back
um to those employees so I can only give
like three quarters of my employees the
perk of giving back some of their
commissions some agents give 25 some
give 50 I give a hundred percent of the
commissions back
and it's illegal to do that to anyone
who does not have an insurance license
so this did pass your committee last
year the best of my knowledge and it got
died because of covet all we want to do
is make ourselves legal Mr chairman
because I know some of our people some
of our agents in New Hampshire are are
um
um are not in compliance with the law by
giving their commissions back to people
in their employee that do not have an
insurance license so this is crafted
very specifically it does not say you
must it just says it's not illegal to do
it so some insurance agent says I don't
want to do that uh I I know there's some
concern that some people that sell other
types of life insurance and annuity
products don't want this to happen to
them well they're that's fine they're
not forced to nor does anyone want to
make them
um this is just any insurance agent who
would like to give back some commissions
to their employees
their employees are not licensed like my
accounting people are not and you know
my human resource people are not
Insurance licensed I can give them their
commissions back without being a
follower of the law
no harm no file that's all I'm trying to
do
um
for our industry so we're legal again
thank you Mr chairman
sure you're not doing it now yet okay of
course not Mr chairman of course I would
we had that yesterday where
okay uh we do have a question
representative Bartlett
thank you Mr chair
um I just reiterate um this is just
just a little benefit for your employees
is that correct representative infantine
yes it is
and um one more question further
question me inquire thank you
um and to repeat what you said we did
pass this last year and it it died on
the table due to the pandemic is that
correct yes ma'am okay thank you thank
you
okay any other questions to
represent the infantine none we thank
you very much thank you Mr chairman
thank you and uh Chris Knight I I
demoted you and then re-promoted you
so I didn't realize that you were also's
fiance you were going to testify here so
welcome again
uh well thank you chairman um I was
again I'm this is not my area of
expertise but I was the other for the
year for the other hearing um you know
the commissioner asked me to just stay
again if you had any questions I'll just
say you know we formally do not take a
position but the department has no
problem in the with this new language it
would be very easy to enforce and or
unin or stop in the other enforcement of
the prohibition
um
it's it's very well defined it's clear
we we know who is you know who is an
employee who is not and uh the number of
people that we're talking about I I my
our impression is that it's a very small
number of people as as uh representative
mentioned then it
it's not something the department has
been worried about to this point maybe
we should be on
okay it's not has not been a problem
um right it has not been a problem it
has not been uh an area a priority at
the department
so
okay is there any other
questions uh for
Mrs uh seeing none uh thank you very
much again Christian and uh I guess if
um no hands are up
in the attendees and I think we're all
set so uh the there were three support
no opposed and the insurance department
is well not just the apartment yeah the
insurance agents and domestic insurance
companies and they're all they're all
neutral on this bill so with that uh
we'll close the public hearing
on uh house bill 518.
and I think we're all set until 1 15.
see we got right on schedule
perfect
so
uh
Keith
uh I have a question for you
yep sure am I moving too quick between
bills or are you I was able to keep up
uh it's when we get to exec sessions and
there's multiple motions the four the
forms they gave me they're not they're
not well designed like if they're
difficult to to manipulate they're all
like Word documents that I have to okay
keep track of so yeah but I was okay
this morning all right great I was a
little I'm just kind of dawned on me
that I was next week yeah thanks for
because
foreign
no it's not beer it's it's cream soda
you know what's really tough for all you
newbies is that so often we get meetings
and lunch provided during committee days
um we'll have lunch in the
um at the Apple Walker house sometimes
they're
um they'll bring them into the cafeteria
the lobbyists like to talk to us and one
of the ways they get us to show up is to
feed us
and a lot of times you know we have
really sharp schedules so
it works out well we don't have to go to
a restaurant or go across the street
um Barley House is a favorite of some of
us
but
um when they feed us we feel you know
like we listen to them we get lunch and
then we can get right back into
committee on time this year that's not
happening so having I'm eating a lot of
peanut butter and jelly looking forward
that's true I miss that Christy
I couldn't miss the camaraderie of all
being around together yeah you know and
and just getting written testimony
really isn't the same as when you're
talking face to face to you know
somebody who's representing
um somebody that's on a bill and you
know for all the bad rap that a
lobbyists get we need them a lot of
times they're really telling us you know
how their constituencies are going to be
affected what this bill will do and we
learn a lot from the lobbyists
um and they're they
you know you you know which side their
Bread's buttered on you know so to speak
you know where it's coming from but it's
it's really helpful often
but lunch is always good too on the
other hand in Concord I couldn't have
gone out cross-country skiing at lunch
I know that my grocery bill has gone up
with my kids being home more yeah for
sure
and now me being home more
sorry barking dogs again
all right you did get outside Joyce you
are red red I know well it that happens
to be in about a second so
it's cold out
yeah but it was pretty nice in the sun
yeah it's a gorgeous day it is a
beautiful day
um
it certainly saves wear and tear on our
vehicles
I know
two devices sorry no
well
I've got a second computer but I've had
all always have a second one it just
went away it went away yeah uh I uh I
only put on like 5 000 miles not 50. on
my vehicle last year uh amazing
theoretically the vehicle will last 10
years longer well be sure be sure to
tell your insurance agent maybe with a a
carrier that gives you a different rate
for low mileage
um
I always we've been in the car business
forever and ever so I only carry a
liability if the car gets smashed up uh
we've got more so
a Manchester's territory one they're the
most expensive in the state
okay uh I guess it's 115 or 117. what
time to go into exact session so uh
Keith
are you
ready for the first motion okay
all right so uh the first bill is house
bill 62.
uh relative to continue in-network
access to certain health care providers
uh
representative greenson seconded by
representative petusic moves in
expedient to legislate and
representative greeson is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker
um chairman uh sorry chairman one of
these days we'll get you there sorry
uh let me uh let me open up the document
I had the wrong one open here so here we
go uh so the uh House Bill 62 FN is
relative to continue to network access
to certain Healthcare Providers the
purpose of this bill uh is to require
access by a covered person to a provider
in the insurance Network directory at
in-network rates for the duration of the
contract for health care services
uh in in listening to the testimony and
uh
determining that it would be in
expedient to legislate because there's
already 60 days of continued coverage in
law for patients and carriers to find
Alternatives and this bill would be
extremely difficult to implement
considering that uh plans and provider
contracts start at various times
throughout the year and they're not all
synchronized to be any one time during
the year so given those two reasons uh
it's determined in expedient to
legislate that's all I have sir
okay
thank you Mr chair
um
we feel a little differently because of
the amendment that was provided by
representative Marsh we'd like to retain
this and work on the amendment
um to try to
coordinate the dates that was brought up
yeah I think the amendment ended up
saying that the that the company had to
the insurance company had to uh
ex honor that previous contract and give
attention to that for that one patient
or whatever patient or that provider and
that doesn't seem
very fair does it
well my feeling is that this bill could
be worked on um to meet the intent
yeah
that's your feeling
okay any more discussion on the motion
of uh inexperience to legislate
okay
all right house bill 62 inexpected to
legislate
uh representative petusic yes
uh yes
representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm
I
representative De Palma
yes
representative greeson
representative Johnson
yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett no
representative
Abel no
representative Herbert no
representative Van Houten no
representative Fargo no
representative bill you
no
representative Burroughs no
representative McAleer no
and representative hunt yes
okay the vote is 10 to 9 the motion
passes okay
so unfortunately retaining is not a
available motion to you
I understand but we would have to
um
that would be the Minority Report would
be OTP
can we bring up the possibility of an
foreign
he'll be back
I'm sure
who will be running the Minority Report
um Joyce do you have thoughts about that
or do you want me to you're a co-sponsor
you're muted I'll do the Minority Report
you'll do it okay okay thank you
oh we have to get um
the chair will be back in a minute I'm
sure you just got frozen and um I did
want to ask whether we can bring up the
possibility of an amendment
um that that might have uh made the bill
um
workable
I take the silence to be a yes
[Laughter]
I'm sure he's running alongside there
he'll be here
I don't understand why you can't put it
a recommendation in The Minority Report
so then the Minority Report would be
ought to pass as amended you're saying
but if that's correct want to do that
then you need to you know include the
text of the amendment in the calendar
oh
so you couldn't just have a
prospective Amendment you need you need
it and now it wasn't um
it was only distributed to us it's not
in
oh no if you want to use
um the the amendment you have in hand
that's fine it's okay to be a formally
drafted Amendment you know I was
thinking you were saying
you wanted to have you know a concept of
a future Amendment with without them
okay no it is a formally drafted
Amendment oh that's fine then you could
have a Minority Report about to pass
this amended okay I'm sure the chairman
would agree with me now looking back now
the chair's back yeah
and he froze again
LLB air is this Pam
good
could I question the council
that was given please anybody hear me
yeah we hear you for the Minority Report
um you know words uh one little word can
mean a lot I think
that what you would want to say is ought
to ought to pass if amended but not as
amended because as amended assumes that
it's been amended and it hasn't been
amended so I would suggest you say ought
to pass if amended
so Pam as long as the amendment is
published in the calendar
yes if you have if you uh that's
certainly an appropriate motion to have
for your minority Amendment an
unfortunately representative Terry we
just
the words we use are as amended you're
correct it's not a past tense but but
that's the that's the motion it is
misleading I I your point is taken and
and that's not what it means
well
there's nothing perfect
my goodness
it's a word of Art
Pam that wouldn't be a floor Amendment
then it would just be an assumption that
the amendment is already appended to the
actual bill correct
right it would be a minority committee
Amendment that's how it would be listed
in the the
minority Amendment would be in the
calendar okay everybody should take note
of the new phrase
uh as a result of the pandemic the chair
and there he is here he is he's back
yes sir
we just passed a lot about he's
speechless
this video is on DSL right now
so uh I I would like
I could wish I could say I could turn
myself off can you guys hear me we can
ah yes man
okay so I can am I okay yeah see I'm on
DSL which is incredibly slow internet uh
right that's what I am on right now yeah
you are oh man
this is this is where I read and say we
gotta have to shut this thing down I
have to
you could turn off
um turn off the video yeah
we can hear you fine John
foreign
holy moly uh video you don't have enough
bandwidth for the video
Mr chairman if I turn my video off Mr
chairman are you invoking a request for
prayer from Representatives
would you like some help here
yes fine intervention
looking for a higher order
okay
Okay so
all right so right now you guys can hear
me right yeah yes everybody can hear me
yep no you can't
well he muted
maybe take a five minute break and do a
reboot
yeah he's got to reset it reboot and uh
behave
foreign
I've got an email from representative
Marsh and he's just confirming that otpa
isn't a loud Motion in a Minority Report
and he's attached his Amendment to the
I'm sorry Christine can you repeat that
I kind of have heard it okay
um there's an email from representative
Marsh
he's on so he can hear what's going on
and he said otpa isn't a loud Motion in
a Minority Report so representative
Weston is going to do the Minority
Report referring to the Amendments that
representative Marsh submitted to us and
it will be published in the calendar
okay and I'm just want to make sure I
understand it all that's why I'm asking
repetition's an important teacher for
most of us yeah hearing it more than
once has helped exactly especially
representative and representative
Marsha's position is what
representative Marsh is the sponsor of
this bill is he a parliamentarian
what you see a parliamentarian he just
spoke authoritatively about what could
be done and I'm just wondering on what
basis he's doing that experience ah
experience he has been in the house a
Christy our representative Bartlett yes
you made a motion uh to retain
um no I know well you did mention
retaining the bill right I can't make
the motion to retain because there was
the motion on the floor was itl
right so
um we in The Minority Report you did
talk about retaining the bill I didn't
hear ought to pass
but it is automatically ought to pass
the other side Autumn pass was Amendment
because we have an amendment that was
that went through OLS and was
distributed to all of us that will be
published in the calendar
and on The Minority Report will refer to
it's complicated
doesn't necessarily make any you know
it's not going to make any difference
the prevailing recommendation from the
committee on the in the calendar will be
itl
okay chair is unfrozen I have uh had to
and that's not me okay so I had to
reboot everything so uh and so uh uh
I'll do say unfortunately right now I'm
down in you know closer to my uh
internet in which I do have two dogs
here so
uh we'll see what happens okay all right
so
um the the uh we were about to call the
call the roll call uh for House Bill uh
62 and how far along do we get we did
the roll call uh Mr chair and we were
just talking about
um was The Minority Report can show a
representative Weston is going to do the
Minority Report okay and um the
amendment that was distributed to all of
us will be published in the calendar in
The Minority Report report will refer to
the amendment Perfect all right you guys
did plenty without me okay all right
next fill up uh House Bill 191 uh
related to Prior authorizations and
patient transfer under Managed Care
Health insurance policies
uh representative patusek second uh uh
by representative Grayson moves uh to
retain
and representative petusic is recognized
thank you Mr chair uh yes I moved to
retain uh the bill ads requirements for
prior authorizations under Managed Care
health benefit plans and the
administration of patient transfers to
another health facility
uh this deal had more people
uh for and against and
a lot of folks
said that it needs further study
uh it really uh could be burdensome if
it's not done correctly so that is the
one of the main reasons why I move to
retain it because there is more work to
be done on this bill and I've had folks
contact me uh saying the same thing and
the same folks that uh
uh testified and they would be willing
to work on it with us so that is why I
okay any discussion on the motion to
retain
representative petusic
yes
representative Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm yes
representative De Palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative Johnson
yes
representative Terry yes
I was a yes yes
representative Abel
yes
representative Herbert
Chris unmute
yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Fargo yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you
yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
representative hunt yes
all right unanimous 19-0 wow
yay the first unanimous vote Mr chairman
can I just interject very quickly while
you were gone there was a discussion
about the the phrasing of the motion and
I want to correct what I said
um representative Terry mentioned that
it should not be ought to pass as
amended and he was correct and and and
it really is ought to pass with
Amendment and the timing is
um
is left up in the air undesignated so
that that is so if it if that motion
prevailed then the amendment would then
get taken up right
yeah if the if the motion uh to uh to
inexperienced fails then you would then
offer up the with them you know we offer
up the amendment right
all right
great glad you cleared that up see will
this be on consent
yes all those in favor placing 165 uh
excuse me 1091 191 on the consent
what's that it's a retained retention
that's right there is no we don't have a
calendar we don't you don't even have to
print a report it just it will just
accounts all the retained bills yeah
exactly
okay uh next up is uh House Bill 165
relative non-compete agreements for
certain mental health professionals uh
representative greeson seconded by
representative petusic moves in
okay
oh representative Bartlett oh um I guess
I'm a little surprised at the motion
um this was something that went through
the labor committee last term was passed
unanimously
um
it was only because it was attached to
the Omnibus bills and this is really
restrained trade
um matters so I'm I'm
surprised that
your side is looking to kill this
because it's not usually a position that
um your side would take
um well if you were to look at the
legislative history of the two other
non-compete bills
uh the first one was Physicians
and the vote was 17-1
and I think I know who that one person
was
second one second time it came through
Commerce the vote was a split vote and
so this time we have it one more time
and at this time the committee was the
Republicans evidently we feel that um
this we got to draw the line and stop it
and frankly if I had my way
I would keep the bill and repeal the
other two because I think I think that
anybody who signs a non you know
non-compete Clause is getting some
remuneration or benefit
for that being put in the contract
we do that or they just didn't read the
contract at all so the fact that we're
going to get in the middle of a
contractual arrangement
and which we don't know the compensation
we don't know whether there was a free
parking space involved in there we don't
know what was the benefit for why it was
put in the contract
and so therefore that's why we feel that
this bill is inappropriate
okay well I will um
I will have to oppose it and I do I I
see it as Restraint of trade and I you
know come from an insurance background
and certainly there's not competes in
insurance but we had some very
compelling testimony I think
that um so have you ever put in a bill
to Vanquish those non-competes
so I'm not
painting this with a broad brush but I
am saying that um we would oppose your
motion I fully appreciate that
dude so I actually did think also that
there was some uh salvageable value to
the bill but it would have really opened
up it's almost like the work we would
have for uh for a a study committee or a
task force
um that there's there's so many issues
there
um so I decided that
what some members said they wanted to do
with the bill with this bill it would be
better off just introducing a new bill
next year
so I'm voting to just itl this and then
hopefully someone will come up with
something uh
somebody has music in the background
okay any more discussion on the motion
of inexped into legislate
seeing on the clerk will call the roll
just to confirm that was greeson
seconded by petusic yes
uh House Bill 165 and expedient to
legislate representative petusic
yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative De Palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett no
representative Abel oh representative
Herbert
no
representative Van Houten no
representative Fargo no
representative Weston no
representative bill you
no
representative Burroughs no
representative McAleer no
representative hunt
yes
okay the voters ten to nine abortion
passes
okay so I assume to be a Minority Report
there will be one does um does anybody
else want to do it or do you want me to
do it
I I would help you if you'd like I could
do it okay I'm gonna put you down
represent it for us
and I assume your emotion will be ought
to pass
all right next up uh House Bill 472
relative to retroactive denials of
previous played
claims representative Terry second by
representative batusic moves to retain
is there any discussion on that motion
yo
yeah I made the motion I'll say
something Mr chairman yes you are
recognized to speak to your motion thank
um
this was a very uh interesting uh bill
and we heard uh very interesting uh
testimony on both uh sides of the uh of
the question
um it uh kind of got the feel of a David
versus Goliath uh situation where of
course the Goliath would be the
insurance companies
which um for for many of us would would
mean that we don't have a great deal of
sympathy uh preliminarily
however I think the most compelling
reason to retain here is because
the uh the time frame of the clawback
was only most recently reduced from 18
months to one year and as I understand
it last year was the first full year of
the one year maximum so I need to give
this a little bit more time and see how
things develop and so I recommend that
we um that we retain
okay representative van helden
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the rest of the committee I think retain
is probably the best uh the best option
right now there is a great deal going on
with this build we do have bipartisan
support we have support across the
bodies of the legislature so there's an
obvious interest I think in getting this
right and making it work so I think the
routine is probably the best thing I
know that we have many constituents and
many followers of the bill who are very
willing to support the retain and to
help us to craft the best Bill possible
I pledge my support there as well thank
you
well yeah I just would have to say that
I'm I'm I'm not happy about this motion
but I am I'm agreeable to it because I
certainly think that there needs to be a
lot more explanation I find that half
the phone calls and I take all my calls
half the people who called actually
admitted Aid and never happened to them
and B it didn't actually cover them and
who their clients were
okay 18 months is a standard number
across the board for all carriers when
it comes to
all other Physicians and all other
practices okay it's is standard and it
turns out that the the biggest problem
was a Medicare Advantage
which of course we don't cover we don't
our legislation doesn't affect it our
legislation doesn't affect orisa plans
and self-insured plans so and all of
those are still at the 18 months and so
that's what what happens is that a lot
of people are very confused or these
providers are confused when they see
this legislation they want to hop on it
but don't realize that they're really
actually going to only make themselves
even more miserable because when they
find out that yes that they did it for
you know they didn't didn't actually
thank you Mr chair
um would you just
re review with us
the time frame of when um our reports
would need to be out
for retained bills so because we know
we're going to have a number of retained
bills can you give us a um just a
refresher on where our commitments would
be when the committee would meet yeah so
my my plan would is between uh retain
bills much like we do with interim study
bills in the second year which is that
uh we would take him up in the fall so
starting in September and October uh we
have two months to work on all the
retained bills and that uh by the end of
October
um I believe is the the date where we
have to have all retained bills out of
committee and they would hit the house
floor uh the first week of January
perfect thank you I missed that first
week of January keep reminding Ed that
when you
but that first week of January is all
the all the hard ones that got retained
represent Van Houten
uh yes thank you Mr chair I want to
thank you for your comments and for your
insights and I assure you that um that
there are issues that go beyond that
that there are practitioners who have
lost money a year a year and a half two
years later who if and the word clawback
I think is so negatively connotative so
it is my it is my intent and my hope to
craft a bill and to actually to help
with the retained Bill to take care of
those issues and to make sure that
nobody is harmed on this not the
insurance companies not the
practitioners and certainly not our
constituents uh as we find that mental
mental health practitioners are starting
to not take insurance because of these
kinds of issues we have a pandemic that
has caused many mental health issues for
people and there are many facets to this
so I'm I'm happy for your thoughts I'm
happy for your willingness to to give
this a chance and I hope that you'll
stay open-minded so that I could
convince you that my way is the right
way
okay so uh anybody else would like to
speak on the motion of retaining
see none the clerk will call the roll
okay and just to review it was
representative Terry seconded by petusic
correct
okay House Bill 472 motion is retained
uh representative petusic yes
representative Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm
ER yes representative De Palma
yes
representative greeson yes
representative Johnson
yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes
representative Abel yes
representative Herbert
yes representative Van Houten yes
representative Fargo yes
representative Weston yes representative
bill you
yes representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and representative hunt
yes
all right 19-0
okay it's a retained bill so we will
hold on to that and work on it this fall
all right next up is uh uh House Bill
519 relative to technical changes in the
laws administered by the insurance
department representative hunt second by
is there any discussion on the motion uh
yeah it's great
it's good
all right any more discussion on the
motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
sorry just catching up here um I
understand
that was uh Auto pass hunt seconded by
all right house bill 519
altar pass representative petusic
uh yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Abramson
aye representative ham
yes representative De Palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative Johnson
yes representative Terry
yes representative Bartlett yes
representative Abel
yes representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Fargo yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and representative hunt
yes
passes all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say aye
aye
stand with the consent calendar is Mr
chair yes
uh they all went through orientation
well
it's usually a good teacher
yeah uh consent calendar uh is a
calendar that that gets voted on at
first and when we first started our
session uh anybody can pull a bill from
the consent calendar but they'll need to
do it prior to the session or at that
moment uh and um and at that point
um the bill everything in that in that
consent calendar will get uh sent uh
their merry way or without debate
okay oh man uh this is why I didn't want
to be here okay so you guys can you go
outside please sorry I'm my internet
um this is uh
oh pants pandas right
um okay uh House Bill 201 relative
review by the insurance department for
coverage of pediatric autoimmune neuro
psychiatric disorders
um representative hunt a second
representative petusic moves to retain
and I will speak to my motion
um I realize uh Christy we have that
amendment that you have there but at
this point what I what I would want to
do is I want to have the insurance
department come in in the fall and tell
us what's going on and at that point in
time we can then do what is appropriate
in terms of what are extending the dates
and reporting dates but that sounds fine
yep you know that way it just it's
cleaner to get that and then rather than
passing an amendment yeah we're fine
with that of course everybody to the
table Yeah okay yep any discussion on
the motion uh to retain
see none yes representative petusic uh
basically in my estimation there's too
much information we won't know about
this
um all right any more discussion on the
motion scene then the clerk will call
the role
retain
Ed I'm gonna dare to move representative
petusic yes
I know representative Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson hi
representative him
yes
representative De Palma yes
representative Johnson yes
yes
representative Terry yes
representative Abel yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Fargo yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew
yes representative Burroughs
representative McAleer yes
and representative hunt yes
19-0
okay uh
let's retain bills so we don't have any
uh Zen calendars that we're moving on
last but not least
um House Bill 343 related to billing for
ambulance services uh
representative West and secondary
representative hand moves to retain
telescope three four three you okay with
that choice uh I didn't ask to retain it
no okay uh representative hand second in
by representative petusic uh a moves to
and uh representative hands recognized
to speak to her motion
thank you very much
um I believe this bill should be
retained
um I think uh in general the goal of
balance billing is is a good goal but
there are small uh rural ambulance
services
across uh our state and in the North
country that may not have the same
ability
um to negotiate to to advocate for their
what they feel is a commercially
commercial commercially reasonable rate
and so we heard some testimony from the
service within my hometown that the
goals are great but there's some things
in there that they would like a little
more time to
um
have some input to work with us and
perhaps it would be a better
bill
um
as a result and so I'm I'm asking that
if you retain so we can work on it some
more here for more rural providers that
seem to be affected more than in the
okay representative Weston
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the committee it is a complex problem
and I think no one knows that better
than me I've talked to a number of those
uh Fire Chiefs and uh just about
everybody who has a stake in this
um I disagree with the recommendation of
itl because a man a ban on balance
billing has been recommended by Tyler
Brennan in the New Hampshire insurance
department for some time and it's a
growing National Trend uh my own
ambition for this bill was to solve the
problem of ambulance reimbursement rates
Statewide and to gain more revenue for
the property tax poor towns like
representative Hamm is talking about
um but because of the difficulties of
this session I scaled it back to focus
on the balance billing for this year but
this is like Groundhog Day this bill
pops up every year and it'll come back
next in the meantime I've been building
a coalition of these people who are
involved in commercial ambulances fire
departments hospitals and everything
else in order to really expand a bill
that deals with the revenue problem for
next year I don't see why we couldn't
pass the balance billing thing in the
meantime
okay
representative Bartlett
um I'm confused representative Weston
the motion is to retain that to IDL
right and the reason I don't want to
retain it for this year I want to get
rid of
I I think we should pass this now I
think we ought to pass the balance
billing part of this
so that people don't get these surprise
bills and then next year we'll deal with
the with the problem that representative
Hamm was addressing about revenue for
okay so I disagree with the idea with
the retain
all right so I I if they're all
integrated okay that that that
um
ambulances are not uh I guess like
mental health it's something different
it's not the way we normally deal with
all our other fee for service uh when it
comes to insurance companies paying for
medical providers uh you know the mental
health is is obviously different because
it goes on it can last for a long time
and it doesn't have to end date you
don't have it easily you're cured you
know solution uh and with the ambulance
it's an even more awkward situation
because the ambulances uh don't get
reimbursed for uh equipment for just
sitting there you know they're waiting
and being there on on in in expectation
that they're going to be needed
um they can only do fee for service and
and
um they're never going to get frankly
never going to get fully reimbursed from
an insurance company and if the balance
Building Concept is that you're going to
get an insurance company to go and I
thought it was pretty clear in the
hearing that the there were plenty of
ambulance providers said it's never
going to work because they a they don't
want to have a contract they don't want
to sign a contract because they don't
want to take them easily amounts of
money the insurance company is going to
be willing to pay and uh that that is
never and then so why we have the
balance building exists is because the
some fire departments really do want it
they want the balance building that I
think I don't know I know you're saying
everybody wants to solve that but that's
not what I heard I heard some ambulance
companies thought it was an appropriate
fee for a user fee and that what really
comes down to is that most in most
ambulance services are somewhat related
to the fire department the fire
departments is something that every
Town's got in their budgets we all
expect to have our fire department we
want our you know that uh to have that
Ambulance Service and just like we want
to have our fire trucks
um but at the end of the day how to
properly reimburse for the fees for the
costs
um when this is really a investment by
each Town each Community to provide an
important service to their community and
every Community has a different value
system everyone has a different way to
do it some have it's a separate
non-profit some is part of their fire
department everyone some of them are
just private private companies so you
know you're you've got a lot of
different
providers all have different agendas
different way to fund it and so to
separate to think that you're going to
solve the balance billing without you
know I I'll tell you I have very
distinct memories of the last time this
bill you know when we last time we dealt
with it it was I had a lot of fire
department a lot of fire people coming
up to me and say
we want the balanced Bill don't take
that away from us and certainly don't
take it away from them if you haven't
solved the the issue of how we're going
to get properly reimbursed for this
equipment and for services
so having said that I will uh take
representative Abramson
um it sounds like somebody's talking
about amending the bill did anyone
actually uh produce an amendment through
oil lessons what she did she's saying
how this bill is different than the
previous Bill how the pre the previous
thank you Mr chair
um
I think I have a concern that I I do
support what representative Weston is
saying I do believe that having uh taken
a piece and working on a piece and then
building to a better uh to a better
resolution with later legislation is a
really good idea
um that leads me to believe that perhaps
retaining might be the better option so
that we can better set the foundation
for that future work I do support
um and applaud the work of
Representative Weston and those that
worked with her but that is my thought
at this point
thank you okay representative Burroughs
thank you um I I could live with it
either way but in support of
Representative Weston I feel that we're
asking consumers to Bear the brunt of a
problem of a broken of a broken business
model on the side of the ambulances and
I I don't think the consumers should be
okay
uh I assume Connie that you just haven't
put your hand down so any any other
discussion on the motion uh to retain
House Bill 343
okay motion is to retain Hospital 3.3
representative petusic yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
aye
representative ham yes
representative De Palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative Johnson
yes representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett no
representative
representative Herbert
no sorry
you're on mute I'll try it again I
apologize no
representative Fargo my apologies no
no representative
Weston no
representative bill you
know
representative Burroughs no
representative McAleer no and
representative hunt
yes
more discussion on the motion I mean
that's what it all said we met the
motion it's retained so we're we're all
done with executive sessions
yeah
yeah it sure is
I I don't know why like Zoom just
crashed on my computer I guess I don't
know what happened but it just cracks
all right uh so we're ready to go into
our uh
uh last hearing for the day House Bill
310 relative to vehicle repairs
and um I don't have my list in front of
me yet but I'm going to go get it but uh
is the sponsor
are you out there the sponsor will you
please raise your hand is it Ken
kenweiler are you there
in there
car broke down
[Laughter]
okay uh no Ken all right uh does someone
have the bill in front who's the
co-sponsor
I guess I'll ask any of the attendees
would like to introduce the bill for Ken
um Representative Steven Smith and
Stapleton are the two co-sponsors Smith
was probably not going to be here
because he's sharing and looking really
I see Smith by itself Smith is that you
raise your hand because that's you if
you like to speak
or maybe that's not
just all it says is Smith
uh
because nobody nobody wants to introduce
the bill for me the only other thought I
have is that if there is a phone caller
I I don't know that that's
representative of color oh okay I got
Walt Stapleton all right
uh you know what Pam you have to turn me
back on again because I uh coming back
in I lost my
head kept co-hosting you and then you
disappeared again exactly
all right there you go
okay
and well Stapleton is coming up there he
is
uh thank you representative Stapleton
for standing in for
okay uh thank you very much
um
for uh letting me be a speaker here and
I was not prepared to present the bill
but in absence of the two others
um I thought I would at least make an
effort to stand in I'm Walt Stapleton
um representative from Claremont ward 3
Sullivan County District Five
and I am a co-sponsor third in line on
this bill
um
HP 310 relative to
vehicle repairs
um I believe this bill
is good for protection against
incomplete inadequate repairs and unfair
Insurance prescriptions and claim
practices
that would uh
um otherwise enable that uh it's
essential that with the complex nature
of automobiles today
that manufactures recommendations
and prescriptions for repairs are are
done accurately and according to what
the engineers have designed for those
Vehicles were
traveling at high speed on highways
there are millions of vehicles uh to
have incomplete and inadequate repairs
jeopardizes the safety of the highway
traveling public
and
um the passengers in those cars
as well as bystanders and pedestrians on
Wayside city streets
um
I I can't speak to any further of the
detail of the bill this is not my area
of expertise but I was proud to uh want
to sponsor it because of the concern for
safety and the complexity that modern
automobiles have today
um so I'm hoping that if you have
questions of the technical nature that's
some following speakers will can testify
better too
um than myself but if I can answer
anything I would be glad to try
uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify on the supporter and co-sponsor
of 310. thank you
okay
remember the uh
conversations about this bill it's a
pretty
intense actually but just for my
edification
the
rebuttal presumption appears in several
aspects of our statutes relative to
liability
and it presumes um that there there is
an expectation
um
uh or a freedom from
um in the case of liability a freedom
from liability that that is reputable
um for instance
um
landowners who allow
um our TV ATV trails snowmobile trails
through their property are given a
certain waiver of liability and that's a
rebuttable presumption
um and if they unless they do something
untoward that would affect the Travelers
otherwise Travelers on those Trails
rights of way have uh
and when they have an accident it can't
go and Sue the landowner just because
the landowner gave her permission but if
the landowner did something like put
something in the trail away
then the rebuttable aspect enables that
to person to challenge the waiver and uh
sue for damages and injuries and in this
case the rebuttable presumption on the
manufacturer's recommendations are
necessary
and if there is something uh variable in
an accident claim situation then that
can be brought to court in a lawsuit to
rebut the Assumption of those necessary
prescriptions for vehicle repairs
I don't know does that help answer the
question well this me uh yes can I
continue chairman for the question so
when it comes to car repairs
the intent of this bill is to allow
independent
uh
shops
access to
um
repair work
even though the even though the uh
the manufacturer May
claim that uh
uh they must do you know their their
designated a dealership must do the
repairs so the rebuttable presumption
allows for the independent shop
shop owner to do business
on these cars is that correct
uh I'm sorry I missed the last few words
of that the the rebuttable presumption
of people's independent shop to do what
to do the repairs to do the repairs
um
I I would say so but the obligation on
the individual shop is to be familiar
with what uh the the
um the manufacturer's recommendations
would be relative to those repairs and
if there's any recalls for instance
um or industry practices that are
prescribed
um it's a moving environment as
Engineers modify some of the parts and
some of the things that they uh they
have that are going wrong or compromised
on vehicles
it doesn't it doesn't preclude
independent shops from being able to do
repairs
all right yep I'm good okay representing
him
thank you thank you Mr chair
um I I guess I have a a series of
questions
um knowing a bit about vehicle repairs
and my family having been in that
business for 50 years
um I just I just wonder
um
and I and I guess I heard it it covers
all vehicles um snow machines or or cars
I I guess this covers everything uh but
uh back to the automobiles um is there
any age of the vehicle or once the
vehicle is out of warranty
um I think I think it might be a little
difficult for independent uh repair
shops
um to be a hundred percent
um familiar with all the
manufacturers manufacturers
um recommended everything as far as a
car is concerned uh when the car is 12
years old or or beyond beyond the
ability to go to the um garage the
dealer to have it repaired
um I'm just I'm just wondering uh what
what vehicles are covered under this
right thank you for the question that's
a great question
um
I I happen to own and restoring uh used
to drive a 1940 Pontiac
um the only manufacturer's
recommendations and I can Avail at this
point are the older manuals repair
manuals probably going up to about 1957
or 58 beyond that it it kind of
evaporates and disappears
and later
um earlier age vehicles uh you know in
the 80s or the 90s there's still
information available
um out of out of very good technical
manuals that you probably have used in
your shop and have a collection of them
on a on a desk and in files
um I think the focus is for these later
newer models of vehicles that are
extremely complex
and those where the sensitivity area is
um
you know my 40 Pontiac doesn't have
Direction segments and uh you know it
has different brake capabilities than
the new cars but the new cars can do all
kinds of things especially with cameras
on them they Park themselves this is
high technical complexity and with that
complexity we we need to have certain
guidelines and to be able to follow them
but it's no different than what we're
experiencing with the zoom phenomenon uh
with remote hearings
um it's Technical and complex and
sometimes difficult and gives us bugs
and problems that are are tough to solve
to get it working so we and when I'm
going to do my vehicle repairs
um and I'm underneath the car because
I've done that for a number of years and
I come across a difficult problem even
on a newer car before I do anything I'll
go to YouTube or I'll go to the
manufacturer site and how to take this
apart and how to assemble it properly so
I don't have a a rework situation and a
breakdown on the road so it is critical
to continue to follow manufacturers
recommendations uh where available
sorry I muted sorry I didn't I mute
thank you for taking my call and my
question
um I'm I'm not mechanically inclined by
any means that's why I have my husband
um I asked him to help me understand
this and I just want to make sure I
understand it
the way I'm reading this is basically
with saying that the insurance companies
are required we're requiring that the
insurance companies
if so there's an accident and my
windshield breaks and they have specific
things in my windshield
that
we're requiring the insurance company to
cover that cost to make sure any
calibrations that need to be done are
covered
based off of the manufacturer's
recommendations because what I I'm
getting kind of confused at some of the
questions because based on how I'm
reading we're basically saying that if a
vehicle is
in an accident and it gets repaired that
some of the insurance companies are not
covering the cost of recalibrating some
of these issues that can come up
and that now the
the owner of the vehicle now has to
cover those calibrations because the
insurance company isn't doing it and I
just want to understand that that's what
we're trying to get at
I I believe so the
um the tendency to understate or under
award a claim I think has been too
prevalent in many circumstances not all
but again with these complex Vehicles
today with cameras backup systems
self-driving self-parking
calibration is absolutely critical and
we don't want the insurance companies to
say well we're maybe it's fifteen
hundred dollar repair but we're only
going to give you a thousand and so he
has to start start to take shortcuts
with uh maybe a secondary piece of
equipment and maybe not so much of the
test and recalibration uh adjustment end
of it
um that that's what we want to avoid
again targeting for safety and complete
effective repair
and we don't want the insurance
companies to cut that effort short uh by
short uh award on adjustments and um
therefore the the bill coordinates
repairs Insurance claim payments with
the necessary repairs as recommended by
so you just felt more of the fact of
like calibrating you know like wheel
census sometimes or like I said the
windshield or backup camera to make sure
everything is in sync as it should be to
make sure it's safe excuse me yeah
okay
yeah go ahead I'm sorry I missed the
question the follow-up question on that
yeah I just wanted to make sure I'm I'm
understanding what the request of this
bill is is that you know it's basically
making sure that the calibrations are
done after an accident so that the
vehicles are safe based on manufactured
specifications and it's not being
ignored as a as a need after an accident
uh correct uh the safety aspect is of
Paramount importance and the um we want
the insurance companies to be sensitive
to that and compliant with that uh and
not uh short uh award any claims for
repairs uh that might compromise the
safety of the repair so uh we're
pointing to the manufacturer's
recommendations for all the aspects of
that particular repair
okay uh next is I'm sorry
um
thank you Mr chair
representative Stapleton would you
believe that we have been working on
this bill for many years we've had study
committees and there will probably be a
lot of people behind you that could
answer some of these questions
yes I would believe that and yeah some
some of these things are tough to get
focused in on and nailed down and I
appreciate all the work you've been
doing uh on this um and I think we still
have to strive for it until we we get it
and get it done so that we can
coordinate insurance with repairs for
safety
okay
uh representative Abramson
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um was it your intent under this bill
that some of these newer cars with those
fancier equipment not use
um you know recycled materials that they
only use new OEM Parts not uh Parts off
um they
for the safe repair
um the OEM
the part that meets the specification is
is primary now can that part be from
recycled materials or from different
manufacturers
um
that's that's a good question and a
tough one to answer and I would have to
say that if the um alternate
manufacturer part or the recycled
material part
um doesn't meet the specifications then
it should not be utilized for the repair
the determination may be that the
difficult uh fact and sometimes the
manufacturers will specify only use
original OEM parts for this particular
repair
and so that's our Flagger warning now
they're going to want to protect their
line of trade and business in doing that
but there's also a safety aspect for
that recommendation as well
um in my my experience of my own car
repairs I've used both
a secondary market parts as well as OEM
Parts sometimes the secondary markets
work sometimes not so bad much and I've
gone to replacing with the dealer uh
manufacturer part even though it's more
money that's generally more reliable and
so as I grow older and want to be
underneath the automobile less and less
especially at winter conditions I'm
inclined to go to the dealer and get the
OEM part and if there's a problem I got
the dealer to bring it back to and then
your view is the right part so if
there's something that breaks down and
it creates a liability I think I've got
a better chance at a defense in court
follow-up
oh he's gone here I'll just ask him all
right yeah go ahead sorry you may
inquire
uh so sometimes when I repair my car
when I'm looking for parts sometimes I
use
uh new copies that are just as good and
sometimes they use uh used OEM Parts
like what you find at a junkyard you
know you know what Max I I hate to do
this to you but
um we have other people who are are much
more intimate exactly what this bill is
and I know like you have a sense of
where you're going with your questions
and and
um I think I think some of the other
people who are going to come up are
probably more appropriate to ask these
questions to because they'll explain to
you this you know the law is if you have
a brand new car
um we're we're the statute requires you
to have to put in uh manufacture the
manufactured Parts but OEM stuff comes
in later so I think it's probably best
that we you hear from other people
um who will testify who can get more uh
articulate what you're I think you're
going with it well no I was actually
just asking what the co-sponsor's intent
what he's trying to accomplish from the
bill
um
I would I would say that the safety and
the coordinate those uh mandate
insurance payments and cover the correct
repair of
um
of the manufacturer's recommendations
and parks for safety of customer quality
and safety
great thank you
um representative Grayson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Staples and and Mr
chairman it may be that I'll have to
defer my question until some sometime
later but I'll ask and then you tell me
if I need to uh if I need to hold off my
question my question is does this bill
enable manufacturers to so specialize
their parts that requires so many
special tools that would require so many
special recommendations as to basically
put your local repair shop out of
business
well that's a good question and um we
are already there relative to um
the specialty technical aspects of
vehicles and special tools and special
procedures
I know myself I don't I won't work on a
uh a a
2020 automobile uh work on my 1940
Pontiac but uh the old the newer the
vehicles got the more complex they are I
don't think it's an intent to drive the
smaller shop out of business I think
it's a challenge for the small business
to keep up with the vehicle the new
vehicle safety and the repair standards
and
um I was in the computer business some
years ago and I got out of it because I
couldn't keep up with it now that wasn't
the intent of the manufacturers and the
Progressive Insurance Hardware it was
just the fact that if I'm going to be a
dealer I've got to keep up with the
latest and be compliant
I think it's just a natural a phenomenon
of an advancing market and and Mark at
okay uh representative Herbert you've
my questions to the chair okay
um and having gone through some of the
hearings in previous sessions yeah my
question to you is
what are the what is the likelihood
of us actually
fixing this bill one way or the other uh
this year
hey
um should we retain it we we might want
to retain it uh you know the history of
this bill just for everyone to say
because uh if I I believe the issue is
that
um the um Auto Body companies uh feel
that the insurance companies are trying
to cut corners on getting cars repaired
is what the issue of this bill is about
so we can take it from there
um it yes we've had this bill multiple
times and and it hasn't done so well it
did pass the committee last year
with a different you know
it was great difficulty and a great
difficulty and different committee mix
yes okay you guys gonna raise your lower
your hands just so I feel okay about uh
okay so um I normally would call on
George russos but I'm Scott Robertson uh
as as in a time frame so time limit so
I'm going to uh invite him to testify at
this point I have
um I'm not sure I have anybody I
certainly don't have anybody who's in
support of the bill who wants to speak
so I wouldn't say to the attendees if
you want to support the bill please
raise your hand so I can get you next
after Scott go ahead Scott hi my name is
Scott Robertson and I am the current
president of the Automotive recyclist
Association where the um for the
association of of
um Auto Salvage facilities throughout
the world
I'm also owner and president of
Robertson's Auto Salvage in Wareham
Massachusetts and our family of
businesses include a brand new GMC truck
dealership and a body shop
so I'd say that I pretty much represent
all three I've managed our body shop
our Salvage facilities and under the
same roof as our dealership I have all
three
and make no doubt about it this bill
here is an oem repair procedure bill
it's just taken a different route
it states within this bill vehicle is
repaired with applicable manufacturer's
recommendations
while the vehicle manufacturers they
only recommend vehicles to be repaired
with their parts and only their parts
they don't allow the use of new
aftermarket they don't allow the the use
of new opt OEM which is a brand new part
that was manufactured by A supplier of
General Motors or Ford or Chrysler but
sold out a different Channel not sold
through the dealership Channel
and it certainly doesn't allow the use
of recycled original equipment parts
most most of you know that that is used
auto parts
[Music]
um
this restricts the consumer's choice and
where and how a vehicle is repaired thus
driving up the costs of the repair
a recycled original equipment part is
not only cheaper but is far better from
the environment than using a new part in
repairs the automotive recycling
industry is actually carbon negative
I know there's a big big push now with
the new Administration about being green
when you buy a used auto part you you're
helping the environment
but
the real crust of this bill is safety
and it's all I hear is safety this bill
mentions safety all the time
it was truly about safety why is it only
for insurance repairs and offer all
repairs
ask yourself that question is the safety
of a person driving is is there a life
worth more if if they're insured and or
not insured
shouldn't it be for all repairs if it's
truly about safety
now the manufacturers have a long
history of putting profits before safety
and I've testified in front of you many
times and I've always said that they've
done that in the past
just look back at the GM ignition switch
GM waited 10 years until recalling and
fixing a known problem because the
injury settlements were cheaper than the
recall
leopards don't change their spots
profits over safety
I just don't think you can trust the
vehicle manufacturers to do the right
thing
I'll take that as a hand up Jane yes it
is a handout it was easier for me to do
this
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh Mr Robertson is this the
right to repair bill that we heard so
much about in Massachusetts no the right
to repay a bill was first passed in
2012. and that was to um for the vehicle
manufacturers to give the independent
repair shop shops access to information
uh the regular repair bill that was just
passed now which now is in court is all
about telematics now the cars nowadays
are very smart and very complex I don't
argue that question at all
um it takes a lot of training to be able
to fix these cars
um but these cars can communicate and
they send data back to the Vehicle
Manufacturer it's where that data goes
and who owns that data if you're driving
a car you might want your car fixed at
your brother-in-law's repair shop and
you want your data to go over to his
repair shop you don't want it to go to
General Motors it you can't even point
it to a dealership you want it to to go
to it goes back to Detroit or wherever
Kentucky where the car is built where
the headquarters are and they decide
what dealer is going to get that
information to contact you to fix that
car
all right thanks thanks for that okay
thank you and just to be sure that uh
recycled parts are almost always OEM
parts that is correct
so you're saying so now with if they're
not using recycled OEM parts to the uh
repair shops sometimes use uh other than
OEM parts for example knockoffs
yes they will use what's called an uh
what What's called an aftermarket part
now if you speak to a Vehicle
Manufacturer they call every part that's
not theirs in aftermarket parts
but in in my industry an aftermarket
part is is a brand new park
that was made by someone other than the
Vehicle Manufacturer it's sort of like
going into
um a CVS and instead of buying a Motrin
you buy a CBS
uh Motrin it's it's it's cheaper
it does the same thing
you know affects your body the same way
all right fair enough well said
all right well thank you very much Mr
okay thank you uh the chair will call on
George russos
I would like just to quickly interject
uh pardon me Mr Russo's I don't know
that um representative Weiler is with us
oh great he um has been on his phone and
um I've re-labeled him by his name so we
can identify which of the phones is him
okay did you put him up as a panelist or
is no I have not done that yet no I I'd
be happy to if you want me to yeah uh
sure because I can't see him at this
point
yeah I I can't move him you'll have to
move them
actually I can only allow him to speak
but he shows up right that's it because
he doesn't yeah okay
uh hello Ken
you need to hit star six representative
I just got your message Pam I was trying
but I just said he now just show you
things are a little delayed here there's
Ken are you there I'm going to click on
ask to remove uh unmute but I don't
think that yeah star six is is what he
needs to do on his keypad and his phone
right star six yeah
and I
I did relay that information through an
email to a staff person all right I'm
unmuted all right good afternoon I've
been working on this for 30 minutes I've
been listening to you when you opened
the hearing I was watching the screen
and I couldn't get on
okay well you're on now
all right
thank you I've got a statement I'd like
to read that's great
all right
for some reason the screen is not in
sync with the phone I don't know why
uh right now we don't have your your
you're on the phone so on our screens as
we we have you and and it tells us that
it's a telephone call that you're
calling in so feel free to go ahead all
all right I've been working on this
issue since sharing a study committee in
2018.
you still there
yeah they're still there I'm I'm
distracted by looking at the screen
because it's it's two minutes off or
something don't don't
uh I've been working on this issue since
chairing a study committee in 2018. we
heard from many independent repair shops
that were not getting a fair deal from
an insurance companies and paying for
vehicle repair
the insurance companies would pay one
rate
I don't know what's going on all right
I can hear a little something in the
background but yeah getting dropped out
no I'm talking still
the repair shops would pay one rate uh
for dealers but would expect to pay less
some of the gimmicks used by the
insurers were sure to find a shop that
would pay bid for Less on the repairs
some laws referred to only using parts
but
the Philippines
all right some law is referred to only
parts of like kind and quality referred
to as LKQ so one company was selling
used parts labeled themselves LKQ
disagreements between the repair shops
and the insurance company went to the
insurance department to be settled the
shops felt that the department was
always biased in favor of the insurance
company even though the department
admitted that their officials that were
sent out to look at the parts were not
qualified repairs sometimes they just
looked at pictures
we passed an earlier bill in this
committee to deal with the problem it's
just about exactly the same bill it also
passed the Senate the Commissioners sure
Insurance went to the commission of
insurance no that had nothing to do with
uh and then it went to the Senate where
it was tabled along with so much of our
other good work
so this bill makes it clear that the
insurance companies cannot ask any
repair to do less than the work that the
vehicles manufacturer says is needed to
restore it to the standard to which it
was made
I had proposed an amendment to the
earlier Bill to have disputes on repairs
judged by a neutral party which you may
still think is necessary such as
Department of Safety vehicle inspectors
that amendment was not adopted but you
might consider it but this is Bill is
the same as you passed last year and
went to the Senate and it passed the
house on a roll call vote I think 216 to
106. thank you
thank you uh will you be able to take
questions
I guess not okay
all right
can you you all said Ken
yeah what I'm watching on the screen
John is about two minutes behind what
we're doing on the phone I was telling
you to stop doing that don't watch on
watch what I'll do okay I'll mute it if
he's watching YouTube That's there's a
delay on that oh the YouTube
YouTube all right
I'm off of YouTube okay great uh where
are you willing to take questions
I am okay representative greeson has a
question
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Weiler uh what happens if
a car cannot be repaired
to the pre-accident condition as
determined by the manufacturer yet would
still be safe enough to pass a state
inspection otherwise
what what happens then
well in some instances this has happened
and then they had an accident and the
accident was not survivable uh somebody
brought up a case in Texas where a roof
was welded on rather than glued on and
you couldn't tell that but the people
died and there was a huge lawsuit
because it wasn't done to the specs you
know somebody tried to sue the
manufacturer because the people should
have survived it but they didn't survive
it because the car was repaired in a way
that was not uh to the manufacturer's
specs so that's one of the reasons why
some of the repairers thought you've got
to go by manufacturer specs because
they're looking at other repair shops
that give them a Bad Name by covering up
so that's the reason you could possibly
drive it but it you wouldn't expect to
have the same warranty and protection
okay
any other questions
on the committee
uh see none we're all set okay well
thank you Ken so you can stay on and
listen in
thank you John and uh all right okay uh
George russos is now
recognized to speak I turned your video
off George oh okay so you have to turn
your video back on if you want one video
or I guess I can turn it back on you
stopped it I'm gonna I'm gonna say ask
to start video there we go there we go
okay
thank you thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee
uh this is uh a topic that is other
speakers have said has been around for
a long time and it's about as
controversial an issue as I've dealt
with uh over the years and um I think
that it's a frustrating issue for a lot
of us to deal with and I would like to
explain why
um
and I think a good starting point
because I think that a lot of what folks
have said expressing concerns about the
current system is based on a lack of to
be candidate a lack of understanding of
how things work today
um this has been pitted as a battle
between the uh the auto repairs and the
insurance company send naturally there's
going to be a tension between the two
the the objective of the auto repair
um like any businessman is to maximize
profits
the objective of the insurance company
is to have work done safely in a timely
manner
and at the lowest cost and so there's
always going to be tensions and that's
why we've seen this bill and other bills
I think over the years proposed by the
automobile dealers and
if I may say I think that it's certainly
not your job to do something to help
insurance companies and we don't ask you
to do that uh I don't think it's your
job to help the auto repairs either the
largest of them are the automobile
dealers
who I believe it's so make more money
repairing Vehicles than selling them
so it's a big business and it's a
business that is increasingly becoming
as automobile repairs become more and
more sophisticated as others have
mentioned uh with the diagnostic tools
that didn't exist 10 years ago and the
ones that are coming in the next five or
ten years uh as it becomes more complex
uh fewer and fewer shops are able to do
the work
and the work is going to some
independent large independent shops they
can afford the Machinery to do scans and
calibrations and repairs uh and a lot of
it to the dealers
now I'm just gonna
talk a little bit
about
manufacturers
recommendations and I think someone who
follows me may go into some more
specifics about that but
man this is not a uh this is not an
instruction manual
this manufacturer's recommendation uh
includes
all kinds thousands and thousands of
communications each vehicle in each
model has its own recommendations that
come from the manufacturer
some of them are sound some of them
clearly uh are not things that uh should
be followed a manufacturer can recommend
whatever they want
there's no control there's no agency
that regulates what a manufacturer
recommends and under this bill
anything that is recommended by the
manufacturer is presumed uh to be
correct and that goes way too far and
they're examples that can be given some
have been
alluded to
uh where the manufacturer for example
says
you can only use
or it says you can only have the part
repaired with the following uh tools
or only by a certified dealer which is
more and more what's going on this is a
very Dynamic field and and repairs the
manufacturers I think it's
very fair to say I prefer the deal with
fewer uh repairs that they have
relationships with and so these
recommendations cut out the independent
dealer that I think a lot of you are
trying to protect and are concerned
about in favor of the large economically
powerful uh repair so again on
manufacturers then there's tons of
examples but one that I recall uh I I
don't remember the manufacturer but uh
it said that if there's any accident
that causes any damage
to the body of the car
the recommendation is that the repair
removes the steering wheel
um
uh look at the sensors and then replace
it which is a two three hundred dollar
repair if I if I recall now Common Sense
tells you uh when and when not to uh to
to perform such a a recommendation of
the manufacturer but under this bill
there's no control whatsoever there's no
check or balance on the part of the
insurance company to be sure that
unnecessary repairs are not performed
let alone that they're not performed at
a at a price that is excessive
so
the question arose under this bill what
um
insurance adjusters and repairs have
been dealing with one another for a
hundred years now
remember
to my knowledge has there been a
standard of rebuttable presumption to
guide them in negotiating repair costs
or what repairs are necessary
that's a newly invented phrase when
applied to this and it takes the
bargaining power uh from an equal one to
one where the repair
uh is presumed if he follows the
manufacturer's recommendation to uh to
be correct
puts a burden on the insurance company
to then say uh no um here's evidence
that you're incorrect no that's not a
that's not a workable way to to do
business
also under the bill and perhaps one of
the most important issues that the bill
presents is at the end they talk about
paint and materials
now you can talk about safety and
suggest that safety is an issue
it really is not an issue and I can talk
a little about that but let's assume
you're right
and you're concerned about safety and we
all are concerned about safety
what do you say about the last part of
the bill
at least with respect to that part I
think we could all agree it has nothing
whatsoever to do with safety
the quality of the of the paint job and
safety are unrelated what we are talking
about is cost
and it's estimated that over half the
cost of repair to a vehicle
is paint and materials sounds like an
awful lot but that's a statistic that I
think is uh holds up
so
about half of the increased cost in this
bill comes from the paint materials uh
section which has nothing to do with
safety
the insurance department has estimated
that this bill would increase Insurance
and that excuse me that is consistent
with what insurance companies uh
estimate
now why in the world with this
legislature want to subject its
constituents to an increase in Insurance
costs and I know you will weigh that
carefully why would you do so well
I think that there's two reasons that
are kind of some of it below the surface
a little bit and some of it right out in
the open and uh uh one is that the
it's presented that the The Little
Dealer is is not getting a fair shake
from the big insurance company and
um the other is that cars are not uh
safely uh repaired now
the safety issue is one that has no
evidence behind it with respect
representative Weiler talks about a
Texas case that every time there's
testimony on this bill they drag out
this Texas case involving sheet metal
six years ago that uh others have looked
at and said that's kind of questionable
to refer to that case in the first place
but if that's the all the only evidence
you have to suggest that vehicles are
being repaired unsafely uh that's that's
not enough to draw any conclusions from
uh it seems obvious that if
the motor vehicles in our state were not
safely repaired we don't know about it
we'd all know about it
I tell you too it's in the interest of
an insurance company that he to have a
satisfied customer
we want the car to be repaired safely
and in a timely manner so in essence
what is the relationships here are that
the
insurance
um
the insurance company stands in the
shoes of the
person who buys Insurance of their
insured
and if you look at it on a standpoint
that you had no insurance
your car was damaged in an accident what
would you do
well you'd want to get the best price
wouldn't you
'd want to have it repaired properly And
Timely
but it's the best price and that's
exactly what the insurance companies do
so
um there's a lot of ground that I could
be covered here
um
it is I I've found it uh
it used to be an interesting issue and
now it's getting to be kind of an old
issue and I'm sure it is for some of you
uh but I hope you will think carefully
uh and and I think too I'm not sure what
the insurance department uh will say to
you today but uh in the past the
insurance department has said
that it opposes this bill it poses it
because of the increased cost and the
bill benefits uh it benefits the
uh
the automobile repair is the big repairs
at the expense of the insurance buying
public
and I I think that that's true
any questions for attorney Russo's
uh I would say
um well James Fox is not here today I'm
not quite he was not able to make it but
his position was neutral
George so just so you know
okay as I see no questions for attorney
russos
uh again I
um like is anybody who would like to
speak in support of the bill I hope you
could raise your hand if you're one of
the attendees
um so that we have a nice balanced
hearing here
um
[Music]
otherwise uh Jim Hayden is next
here we go
so uh thank you Mr chairman uh members
of the committee uh Jim Hayden again on
behalf of State Farm insurance companies
which uh frankly is one of those
countries in New Hampshire's largest
insurer of automobiles
um we uh have
been opposed to this bill and this idea
since the first day it was introduced
uh two or three years ago
um I'm not too sure of what variation of
the build this is now
um but it is I think where it left off
last year
um and I think in the best way to
explain our opposition to this bill is
to really go back and touch on a few
points that George mentioned but try to
put it in the context of how water
repairs are handled under the laws of
New Hampshire and you know I think we
need to First Focus uh on the fact that
under our existing lives you know
insurance companies are not allowed to
steer business to automobile repairs
um if you're in an accident or in your
car is damaged you are free to choose
any consumers free to choose uh the auto
body of his or her choice
um
basically uh in that context you know
the insurer is required to pay for the
repairs but he's not required to uh pay
more than the fair and reasonable price
for the repairs and by this process it
allows the consumers their choice but it
also protects the insurance company from
being overcharged for those repairs and
effectively this bill tries to wipe out
that whole dynamic
um when an automobile is damaging an
insured accident an insurance adjuster
or the repair shop identifies the
repairs uh required to restore the
vehicle to the pre-loss condition
there's an estimate prepared to listen
it details what needs to be done and
once that estimate is prepared there are
discussions and negotiations between the
insurance adjuster and the repair
facility regarding the scope of the
repairs in this specific parts we needed
and the vast majority of cases I mean
the entirely vast amount of times
those I worked out without any real
disputes
um but in this process and in this
negotiation and in this discussion you
know the insurers uh and repairs know
that the auto manufacturers have an
informed perspective about how to repair
a car uh the auto repairs have review
have views on the property pairs because
they've learned how to fix them and the
insurance company has views on how it
should be done because frankly they
adjust thousands and thousands of auto
repairs and they everybody shares a
common goal of a proper repair of an
automobile
but it's only the insurers
uh goal of ensuring that the price is
not excessive and that's because they
ultimately would need to pass the cost
of the repairs along to their customers
and no company would ever want to do
that if and be forced to pass along an
unnecessary cost
um this bill really tries to eliminate
the insurance company from that
discussion and and that is really why it
disrupts the economics of an auto repair
process and that by itself should be the
reason to reject the bill as a whole
um we have heard that
um
um we have heard before that the
insurance department
um was concerned about how this bill or
how this type of Bill could raise rates
it is the reason that the governor
vetoed the bill two sessions ago
um and I think that you know the
proponents of this bill would rather not
think about these types of things and I
think we need to have to confront them
here today
um
but we also can focus on
the the need to save for safe repairs
because if you read between the lines
you know to the extent any of this is
driven by safe repairs this bill is
actually inconsistent because it really
uh allows an auto repair to ignore a
manufacturer's procedures because it
doesn't require that all person all
prepares all the manufacturers
procedures it just says if they choose
to follow them an insurance company has
to pay for and that means that they
would necessarily have an incentive to
choose the most expensive repair when an
insurance company was paying for
um and they frankly argue that
the they themselves so the sole arbit of
of repairs and the safety of cars and
the fact is that's not true at all state
farming 110 other insurance companies
show their support for Highway Safety
and the safety cars through their
support of the Insurance Institute for
Highway Safety uh and they're the folks
who inform all of us about the safety of
automobiles through independent
scientific and educational
organizational studies
sorry
um so we learned from their hard work
um and so with that uh
there's at least some overtone that this
bill would
um
support small body shops and allow them
to flourish I think you've heard earlier
testimony how
um it would there's most of the small
body shops are not associated with
manufacturers and I mean and auto
dealers
um it's while it may have some small
benefit to smaller body shops it would
have a disproportionate uh benefit to
the larger body shops
um and I thought that George alluded to
you know how this bill might work and
the fact that it's tied to procedures
um and I called all data it's in all
caps which is uh is a website that
provides manufacturing prayer procedures
to to the collision repair industry and
when I asked him ask the person on the
other under the phone the customer
service rep how many repair procedures
are out there he said well frankly he
grunted and said a lot and estimated
that their database holds 10 000 or more
OEM procedures and I thought I would
share with you uh a short uh slide a few
slides that I prepared that shows you
how these procedures play into uh the
repair process and how it would impact
the adjustment of a claim and the cost
of that claim and I will try to share a
screen right now
I hope this is short
and I will make it short yeah we want
the edited verb version
okay
so uh
this is the this is a picture of a
2015 Altima
um you can see in the front where the
license plate there's some small damage
to the license plate holder and the
bumper
uh there's a closer shot
of the bumper and the damage and in the
normal course the adjuster for the
insurance company would uh look at this
and make a visual inspection and uh and
decide how much it would cost just to
fix the what's obviously broken and what
they can see uh from with the naked eye
but that also its industry standard that
they would also uh allow the repair shop
to come back and identify uh additional
damage that was not seen by the naked
eye
um and this is a screenshot of the
repairs and the parts and the processes
that would be conducted uh in order to
repair the car properly and you can see
the cost there is 746 dollars
um then when you start looking at the
manufacturer's procedures uh you can see
that
um you know in this accident the driver
airbag was not activated but as uh Mr
russos mentioned you know this procedure
would require the removal of the airbag
and the checking of the cover and the
terminals uh even though it's obvious
that the damage was not so severe that
there would be any impact on the airbag
um and you can see further on
where the procedure would require some
investigation of the center pillar in a
place that seat belt tensioner
um you can see where it would require
removal of a seat assembly
and I could go on but by the time you
end up adding up all those repairs the
repair uh the repair estimate grows
substantially in time and parts and the
total cost ends up being 2
256.26 nearly three times the current
cost and the issue with respect to this
bill Mr chairman is
on the screen share
um
is that
you
all right see you did it went to your
desktop no it did okay so um
now you got to turn off your screen
sharing
all right so am I back to where I should
be Mr chairman as far as I still see
screen sharing you got you haven't
turned it off
oh I was doing pretty well for most of
that yeah
um he should be able to do it like stop
do we have
I don't see that I can stop sharing I
can stop I see I stopped participating
sharing oh you just cut off the ability
I don't know thank you I was just
catching up to my end so to to wrap up
you know I think you'd see fairly
dramatically how you know what in one
situation how just the blind adherents
the procedures uh really has an
inflationary aspect on the cost of
repairs and if the insurance company
does not have the ability to push back
and reject uh these unnecessary repairs
um the cost of that would inevitably
flow through back to the cost of
premiums and for this reason and for
many others uh State Farm opposes this
bill in any form in this idea in any
form thank you
thank you is anybody have any questions
uh seeing none thank you very much Jim
and I'll invite you to speak Andreas
you are muted
you have to turn your mute off yeah
perfect that better everybody hear me I
can hear you now ah perfect perfect
good afternoon chairman hunt members of
the committee my name is Andreas and I'm
the government Affairs manager for LKQ
Corporation in the Northeast thank you
for giving me the opportunity to testify
in opposition to house bill 310.
uh LKQ is the leading provider of
alternative and Specialty Parts repair
and accessorize Automobiles and vehicles
I know we got into it a little bit about
aftermarket parts and recycled Parts
well we're you know we're one of the
biggest sellers of both of those
Nationwide we have two facilities in New
Hampshire one in Manchester and one in
Londonderry
um but I'm not going to focus on the
part so much today is I'm going to focus
on the scanning and calibration aspect
of this uh through the years we've
Diversified we own paint companies we
own uh
we're getting into more of the
telematics but also uh We've also
created a company called Elite Tech
vehicle services now uh delete Tech is a
scanning a mobile scanning and
calibration company in fact we are now
the largest U.S provider of mobile and
on-site calibrations Diagnostics and
programming vehicle services for fleets
and auto repairs
we fully support restoring repairing and
calibrating the Adas systems which are
your backup cameras and your lane stay
in the lane type technology so we fully
support repairing those to a proper
working order and as a matter of public
safety policy makers should encourage
technicians insurers and vehicle owners
to maintain those systems to the
industry to the best industry standards
however we support ongoing development
for a professional certifications for
automotive service Excellence which is
one of these uh certifications instead
of following uh the manufacturer's own
uh procedures the issues in this bill
have been continue to be controversial
for those involved on all parts for a
long time now uh it seems to address
vehicle repair procedures as they relate
to skin and calibrations of these Adas
systems
and however the use of the main word
manufacturer recommendations inevitably
limits innovation
competition and impacts the type of
parts that are used to repair vehicles
while these Adas systems are complex the
underlying challenge is not that
technical in nature rather these
automakers the oems through
mystification and often via their
monopolistic practices they create
barriers to servicing and repairing
their own products bottom line they want
you to go to their shop using their
equipment using their parts
by mandating the recurs and insurers uh
follow these these rules you'd be
limiting many modern more efficient
methods to scan and calibrate Vehicles
sometimes these procedures for preparing
a car may be 10 years old they're not
always updated in that amount of time
better and more efficient after-market
tools are used to calibrate now do you
want to
calibrate your vehicle with a string and
a dongle or do you want to use a lake
you want them using the newest
technology something that we would use
well this Bell essentially would prevent
us from using newer better technology
and force us to use some outdated older
manufacturer procedures that might not
be the best for repairing your vehicle
anymore
in addition having to follow these
recommendations will often Force
customers to get their cars repaired at
an oem repair shop I.E the dealer this
instead of going to an independent
repair these shops only use new OEM
Parts meaning that the alternative Parts
like recycled and aftermarket are left
out of the loop recycled aftermarket
parts often provide consumers with
better warranties better prices better
availability and the limiting these
creates an unlevel playing field against
the alternative Parts industry in favor
of the car manufacturers
without competition the oems are free to
charge whatever they want for their
parts and the cost of repairs and the
that's pretty much all I have to say I
don't want to repeat what some of uh the
other opponents have said but uh if
there are any questions
um I'm happy to answer them but we we
hope that you have heard my arguments
and vote no on this issue it's just not
ready to go there's a lot more going on
behind the scenes than than it appears
it's not about safety as we've beaten
this to death that we're about safety
then the men then it would be on the
repairer to follow these procedures
every time and then they would be on the
hook for liability not putting it over
to the insurers only on insurance
repairs thank you very much
thank you are there any questions from
the members of the committee
uh seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you I have one more
person signed up so if any other
attendees want to speak you need to
raise your hand and that is Cindy blade
block
and uh
so Sandy you can start testifying
hello
excuse me Mr chairman and members of the
committee sorry about that Mike
computer screen went live there for a
minute my name is Sandy Blaylock I'm the
executive director of the automotive
recyclers Association more commonly
known as ARA we were established in 1943
and today represent the interest of over
4 500 Professional Automotive recyclers
across the U.S as well as 17 countries
internationally
our members are dedicated to the
efficient removal and reutilization of
genuine original equipment manufactured
or more commonly referred to as OEM
automotive parts
we are concerned that the language
contained in House Bill 310 would have
severe anti-competitive consequences for
consumers Professional Automotive
recyclers and independent repair
professionals in New Hampshire as well
as elsewhere
art industry does support that industry
repair standards for automotive repairs
should be well defined as to the process
necessary to assure that the vehicles
are returned to their pre-loss condition
as closely as possible however we do not
support repair procedures that disallow
the usage of recycled original equipment
parts or denies the consumer choice of
what parts are used and repair of their
vehicles we're also bothered as several
other people have mentioned uh the
establishment of a rebuttable
presumption which technically means it's
true unless somebody comes forward to
contest and prove it otherwise that
Automotive manufacturer's
recommendations for scans and
calibrations are necessary for vehicle
repair
um you know over the last 10 years
manufacturers have been much more
aggressive in their efforts to force
recycled original equipment parts out of
the market by releasing these position
statements uh repair specifications and
procedures that are often biased and
based on week or no apparent scientific
research claiming that recycled OEM
parts are inferior to new OEM parts
uh we we feel that house bill 310 is
just another attempt to do just that uh
we're also bothered by the references to
the paint material guidelines uh that
they're necessary and uh I think you've
seen examples of how that could it could
go awry in many many many ways so we're
urging uh this committee uh to consider
the consumer
aspects of this and uh we we urgently
oppose the uh or ask you to oppose the
legislation today uh thank you for
testifying or thank you for allowing me
to testify and I do have I am a former
Auto Recycler so if you have any
questions for me I'll be glad to ask
them from that perspective as well thank
you yay
uh any questions representative aberson
has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you oh the
video is not starting
there you are you are can you see me now
yes we can sorry about that uh so I've
always thought that questions like these
uh should be made by the consumer but
I'm not sure if there's some possible
way to uh let consumers choose the
higher priced
uh option versus the uh
allowing them to use uh allowing the
repair facility to use uh something
other than OEM equipment or allowing
them to use uh recycled equipment or
calibration you know different
I feel it's as a consumer myself and and
somebody who's who has many vehicles
anywhere from a 1927 all the way up to
2020. I can tell you that um
our business that we had for many years
in Albuquerque New Mexico
um
95 of our business was was wholesale so
we went directly to the repair
facilities that trusted us for many
years to give them a quality product to
return to return their uh customers
vehicle back to pre-loss condition
um we really never had a lot of problems
with consumers uh choosing our parts uh
as a matter of fact some of my
warranties were uh better than some of
the OE warranty so
um for example every part that I sold
came with a minimum of one year parts
and labor so if anything happened to any
part that I sold it was replaced uh and
and they were paid to replace that part
so I think at the end of the day
um
you know today's vehicles are are
technically Advanced but they've been
technically Advanced every year as as
time has gone along so this is not the
first time that we've uh seen some of
these situations as as the bodies of the
okay uh any other question sure miss
Blue Line see none thank you very much
for your testimony
and
uh or why can't I say oh there we go
okay Tom Tucker
and I'm Tom I'm promoting you up to the
and
can you hear me Mr chairman yes we can
all right good afternoon everyone Mr
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is Tom Tucker I am the senior
director of government Affairs for the
Auto Care Association the Auto Care
Association is a national trade
Association comprised of more than 3 000
member companies and Affiliates
and manufacture distribute and sell
motor vehicle parts and accessories
tools and equipment Nationwide in short
we represent the entire supply chain of
the Auto industry and on behalf of the
industry we're opposed to house bill
310. there's a lot been said today this
has been a very long hearing so I'm
going to be very brief with just two
points I'd like to make to the committee
uh first our main issue is with Section
e of this bill section e says in this
paragraph manufactures recommendations
for scans and calibrations means a
manufacturer's written procedures specs
tolerance and other technical
requirements
um as you've already heard you know when
you start talking about manufacturer's
recommendation and procedures you're
really getting into it's no longer about
safety you're you're getting into
recommendations that uh means using OEM
tools for scanning and calibration uh
representative
um I can't think of her name she's she's
no longer on the call but she asked the
question earlier today does this have
anything to do with right to repair
and uh our my colleague Scott said no
but it actually does
when right to repair was uh first fought
in Massachusetts in 2015.
there's a National Partnership between
the vehicle manufacturers the Auto Care
Association where I work for and we
represent the aftermarket that
partnership says that beginning in model
year 2018. the vehicle manufacturers
must send to every tool manufacturer or
at least make it available in the cloud
download any information
dealing with scan tool equipment so
we're talking about
um security security information specs
security patches updates so the Tool uh
manufacturers can manufacture
aftermarket scan tools the problem is
today that technology is moving faster
than legislation and the regulatory
process and so the oems have now
installed secure gateways that now
blocks aftermarket scan tools from
accessing of vehicle diagnostic
computers computer systems
so if you don't know what a secure
Gateway is it's nothing more than a
cyber barrier or a checkpoint that keeps
unauthorized traffic from entering and
organization's Network and so this is a
major barrier and that's what this bill
would require that you have to use the
OEM Network because uh the the
aftermarket systems would be blocked
second if independent repair shops are
using aftermarket scan tools which many
are and they're being blocked then the
car is going to end up having to go back
to the OEM franchise dealer networks and
they're going to ultimately use OEM
Parts which is going to raise the cost
of the repair this has now become the
anti-competitive issue that impacts
local and small businesses in your
communities and so I certainly would ask
you to think about the pandemic and
what's happening and while our industry
has been declared essential
most people were staying at home they
weren't getting repairs done and so the
impact of the industry is uh businesses
what business was not flowing at the
same way before the pandemic so this
bill will ultimately hurt local and
small businesses uh in in the State uh
finally OEM recommendations always
specify the use of OEM parts
um and while this is is not outlined in
the bill it is an unintended consequence
of this legislation and so for these
reasons we respectfully ask you the vote
knowing this bill and I thank you for
your time and I'd be more than happy to
answer any questions that anyone may
have
great thank you uh is there any
questions from any committee members
I think they're questioned out
great thank you very much thank you very
much
all right so I don't see any more hands
up
uh on either side of the aisle here
um so I guess we can uh
wrap up the public hearing here and I
would just note that the
um there was five five in support 14 to
pose and two neutral
on the bill and with that I will close
the public hearing on House Bill 310.
and uh that ends our
hearings for today